Streamlabs has banned me for 5 years because I laughed at a racist
donation somebody sent in.
That's why I'm banned from >> Destiny is coming to realize
that the thing that like works against him most as a serious
political actor is the fact that he had these insanely degenerate
DMs leak, right? That's what that's what actually works against
him as a serious political commentator and people can diaper.
Yeah, the weird diaper puts people off, bro. I'm sorry. It really
do. like Ky Farmer. He's not like on Reddit or second go on these
places sometimes. Maybe on Twitter mainly Twitter really only
uses Twitter. Maybe he doesn't go on Reddit and go Discord anything
just Twitter. So if you don't type that on Twitter if you don't
make announcement I will really find out. >> You're right.
>> Sorry. Where was the funny thumbnail though? Yeah. At
the end Destiny clears his name and it's 3 hours with like logs
of people logs of kosher Kathy mocking him. This proves that
apparently Queenman's community and my community docks people.
>> Wait, ironically, wasn't that also the title of the
Keles's manifesto? >> Uh, might be. Could be. >> The
end of all things.
I've got like an memory for this stuff. >> J has been ignoring
us for hours. No, I haven't. Shut up. No, I No, I haven't. No,
I haven't. >> Yeah, it was. >> The end of all things
was the Keell's
>> Oh, right. The end of all things. Sure.
And it's just it's hilarious how closely it all maps on to the
exact [__] he's been doing the whole time. It's crazy.
>> Okay, hold on. Uh
there's my two Hassan laughs. And Hassan is bad. There you go.
There it is.
Fine. Sorry. People can pay channels to get those stupid emotes.
Those are on cool down by the way. Don't spend your points right
now. Jesus. For a second though, I thought you were mocking my
laugh. What the dude? It's just just stopping the convers. Hold
on. Hold on. What the >> No. Hassan does this like high
pitched dolphin laugh. He does this all the time. It's a good
one. >> Boing boing boing. You all right. Um yeah. Oh my
god. Me. You've got a lot of content to cover. Um especially
>> I got to catch up on so much. >> Good conversation.
>> It's good. >> It's good. You're in for a treat.
>> I will cover that. I'm now I'm suddenly like so I'm
trying to reach out touch in private just to like have a word
with him cuz I think unfortunately I just think he's been like
lied to blatantly about what happened with um like how he was
doxed and stuff. I think there there's an intentional repainting
of like all stuff that's happened to people around Destiny that's
bad from before January 20th before this all blew up before I
was against Destiny has been pu pushed onto my community and
Queman's community and it's like no I don't have responsibility
for your Kiwi Farms thread. Oh, it's an Auggie tweet guys. Sorry,
this is a not sword. I I should maybe not keep that up. Oh boy.
um
what was I saying? Oh, that's all. It's been a solid effort to
push all of that on >> the stream. What are you talking
about? >> Sorry. Go on. >> It's not a swastika. It's
the other way around. It's an anime sword. It's from Bleach.
I know what it is. It's just a little joke. Okay. So, pushing
pushing all of these actions. So, all this stuff, these people
were all docks, right? And they go to those friends of Destiny
and say, "You can't talk to Jtock or Quean." Like, you can't
talk to them. Hutch talked about it on his stream. Like, I was
going to talk to Quean and then somebody approached me and said,
"Hey, this guy's really unhinged." And then, um, his information
got reposted in that thread. And then he basically was like,
"Oh, this is because of Quean because somebody told him it's
because of Quean."
And it's like, "No, it's not." >> Chops was gassing up
how like Quimman's like an evil amoral guy with what did what
did Chop say? Like no principles or something like that. I don't
know.
Um, obviously without understand the personal bias that it's
like, yeah, obviously getting a very very one-sided story of
a lot of that drama, but yeah.
yeah. I mean, I'm going to him. I think I said this earlier.
I put a message in his chat, but he's covering other stuff, so,
you know, whatever. Not going to press it there. Um, probably
going to send him an email maybe. Um, yeah, cuz he he doesn't
seem like he's in the loop with like I don't know, the malicious
kind of like narrative crashing or anything like that. I think
he genuinely just feels like I don't know like he's been burnt
by a lot of like lefttoid communities and yeah, he kind of believes
a lot of these narratives based on that. Yeah, I think he just
trusts these people because he hasn't seen them be like super
untrustworthy. But it's like that's why I'm I'm not trying to
cast like a ton of um like anger or doubt on him in general.
I just I feel like that would be if I go and like review his
stream and I go like hard on him, I feel like that's going to
be super counterproductive, right?
>> Um we'll see. We'll see how I'm going to cover that.
I don't know. >> I feel like everything that I've seen
of Hutch and as much as like cuz I did go over the stream earlier.
Um, and as much as more of my comments might have seem a little
bit a little bit harsh, um, I think he just doesn't understand
like how commentary works, I don't think he understands like
commentary standards in terms of like asking Queman to like say
stuff on stream that he might not actually believe. Um, I just
think he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't get it right. Um, so it's
been like a big misread there. And uh, yeah, Hutch just seems
like a like a nice guy who's just a little bit I don't know.
It's weird cuz he's like he always talks about his age but like
wet behind the ears or like he just he comes across as like somewhat
naive in a weird way. >> I I think that that he's talked
about it and I don't really hold this against him but he went
to narcotics anonymous, right? Like he had an addictions problem
and a part of that program is forgiveness, right? Like literally
seeking forgiveness and forgiving other people for really bad
things. And so he I think he just approaches life that way and
like I'm going to forgive these people. But I don't think he
like is forgiving people. I think he'd need to see like contrition.
I I just think he has a really he he doesn't see all the information
and he thinks all of these people around me are like rational
actors who wouldn't mislead me. Like they would never just lie
to me about stuff. They would never totally mislead me on stuff.
And so I just wanted to present like some of the information
to him about how he was doxed, why this happened like cuz I I
think he doesn't understand. If you want to not be doxed, it's
there there are people who will just go after the people around
Destiny. If you don't want this, then you probably can't be around
Destiny. Just because you're fighting with people who don't like
Destiny does not mean that you're going to have this happen,
right?
Like like you if if you care about the pattern, the actual pattern
here is if you're close to Destiny, um he is inflammatory enough,
he is he he gasses up his his like haters as much as he possibly
can too, right? Like he that's why he'll directly read the thread.
That's why he'll directly engage with the thread. That's why
he's posted in the thread. He loves just like gassing up the
people who dislike him. And it's like that's the pattern you
should probably be watching out for if you don't want this stuff
to happen. It's not going to be Queman being mad at you. That's
not what's going to h that's not what's going to cause this.
Queman if Queen came out and went Hutch isn't a DGER. He's not
an orbiter, guys. And then Hutch goes and does a podcast with
not soite. That's Quean suddenly putting himself in the crosshairs
for you after you already maligned him once. Already said he
was like a total who shouldn't be engaged with, right? Based
on a DM from somebody else. >> Yeah. Yeah. So, um I >> yeah,
I I think I might have actually said the exact same thing verbatim
um when I was covering Hutch earlier. Um yeah, that's where the
risk is coming from. Even kind of like giving defense for Destiny
on this stuff. I Yeah, I mean, I just Yeah, he he just seems
like a naive kind of like video games guy who's moving into politics
and maybe doesn't understand like what the temperature is like.
I think a quote from his stream earlier was um I mean it's kind
of a misspeak so you know take it with a grain of salt. Why are
people going and doing a civil war over
>> was the uh direct quote direct quote from his uh from
>> dude from his his stream earlier. >> Crazy. It's
crazy.
>> It's wild. >> He just doesn't know what he's going
in for. But yeah, if there is anything that like online doxing
is going to happen over, of course it's going to be online
>> All right. I think um I got to get to some of this content.
I think you're going to end your stream. So, thank you for coming
on. Super appreciate it. >> No. No. >> Super appreciate
me on dude. I'll uh I'll chat to you later, right? Have a good
one. >> Yeah. See you. >> Sounds good. Talk to you
later. Bye. I probably should have said have a good one back.
I was just terrified I was going to say have a good stream, too.
When he's clearly ending his stream. Anyway, guys, let's uh
let's continue. Finally, we are getting to the content. Content.
Content. Content. So,
where do we start here today? Do we start with the Auggie Chud
combo? Do I start with the Auggie Chud combo? I think I do. I
think I do. So, guys, we we covered the the Willie Mack video
last night, right? >> The range freaks that hate you. >> We
covered the Willy Mh. We covered the Willy Mack video last night.
Let me get through to where Auggie comes on. There it is. >> Okay.
Oh, this is just about it. Covered the Willy Mack video last
night. Willie Mack went hard at Auggie um with very little reason
and Auggie decided like I guess if you're just going to leak
about my life. Well, I'm gonna come back on you. I'm I'm gonna
come back at you. So Auggie does a little bit of um some counter
leaking, talks a little and says that he'll be responding tonight.
I think he will respond tonight. I think he actually is in the
active process for responding process of responding, but we need
to catch up on the whole day. Okay, I need to catch you guys
up on the whole day so we can save that Augie stuff for a little
bit later in the stream. Let's cover uh the Chud interview with
Auggie right now. >> Let's see. Let's see about this.
>> yo, Auggie, how's it going? >> What's going on,
man? Uh long time no
>> Um yeah, I think the last time that we spoke was the
uh the the New Year stream, in fact,
>> actually. Yeah, that's kind of crazy. Well, maybe during
the Destiny drama, we talked a bit during that, but yeah. Oh,
uh Anonymous, thank you for the gifted sub. Okay, to your hero
2 minutes ago. Forgot to say thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I mean, that that stream, if you're aware, has been uh very uh
very famous, much discussed. >> Well, dude, I feel like
I've uh surpassed the amount of trouble that I was in from that
stream with my own comeback stream I did two weeks ago. I think
everything I said on that stream got me into some sort of trouble
in like every community that I covered that stream. It's actually
insane. >> And just when I thought I was out of the weeds,
this Willie video just drops out of nowhere. like genuinely like
so
>> slow down. Wait, >> we got some other business
to attend to, mate. I made some comments about you, didn't I?
>> Chud talk to one of AI streams. It's not a big deal.
>> So, yeah. I mean, dude, I >> Good question. Good
question, though. >> You say your piece. What What have
you got to say for yourself? Like, what's going on, mate?
>> Yeah. I mean, there's a lot. And obviously, I'm going
to be, you know, responding to this on my own platform. I kind
of have to. Um, but I mean Willie is very obviously hurt. I mean,
he's been uh I think Queman and Jtock, but probably particularly
Queman, although he does really hate Jtock and he doesn't like
you either, by the way. And I'm fine talking about that because
>> this is, by the way, this is the group chat leaks. >> Clearly,
he has no [__] issue disclosing anything that we've
ever talked about. So, I mean, >> okay, let's be narcissistic.
Hit me. Hit me. What's the problem with with it with Chloic?
What's going on? Uh, I I don't care. Don't Don't talk about it.
Don't talk about Willie Mac's wife. You don't have to talk about
Willie Mac's wife, okay? Don't come to my chat to talk about
Will's wife. I don't give a [__] about Will's wife.
All right? I don't have any problem with her. She never done
anything to me. Shut the [__] up about Will's wife.
I think he just doesn't I think there's a big paranoia
uh of like an anti community. You know what I mean? I think there's
a big paranoia with an anti- community. And
guys, there's a big paranoia with an anti community. You know
what we should do? We should just lie about these guys repeatedly.
That'll solve it. How do we fix the anti- community problem?
Uh lie about everybody we perceive as being a part of it regardless
of what their actual opinions are. I think Queenan and Jtock
are sort of uh looked at as these like figures that are uh you
know they can't be trusted. They might do and say crazy [__]
They might form audiences that are just going to be a pain in
our ass. I think that's a lot of where it comes down from. And
I think in general, you know, my biggest issue with Willie is
that he's not able to sort of uh consider the criticism and see
if there's any value to it, you know, like cuz I think when you
get criticized, obviously you should you shouldn't just dismiss
it immediately cuz what if it's true, you know? You don't want
to just be hard stuck on one path. And so when he's getting criticism
for his Destiny video, I think he immediately like just throws
it in the trash. He's just like, "Ah, this is just stupid [__]
This is just spurouts. These are, you know, Destiny snark communities
that are coming at me with all this bullit. But I I prefer to
>> The funny thing is is like I swear to God, this thing
that started all of this was apparently me arguing with him on
that Queen stream and I just came in like I was I wasn't like
preparing criticism. I was like, I'd heard that like he just
like kind of not included a bunch of the weird stuff around uh
like Desi's responses to to Cherry and Pixie, like the allegations,
the the oh, I'm going to malign these people's reputations, which
by the way has been key in him trying to right, he just called
Pixie like a sick demon recently. He totally like tries to trash
Cherry whenever he can, right? It's a key part of how he actually
gets his community to get back on his side. He will continue
to attack the reputations of these people. It is an incredibly
important thing to point out the pattern of behavior if you're
criticizing this person, right? It's incredibly important. It's
always relevant,
right? And when I jumped onto that stream and was just like,
"Hey, I think this is pretty important." Willie was like, "No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I included everything. This is okay.
This is okay." It's like, "Bro, I I really think if you watch
Ryan Beard video, you'll you'll find it's not quite okay. It's
not quite good enough. I swear. I promise." >> Like, "Hey,
let's, you know, sit down. >> Anyway, I hopped on that
stream with no ill will." No, it will at all. I was just like,
"Chill, bro." I was totally chill. Apparently, I can go kind
of hard sometimes, but I think I said during that conversation,
I was like, "My bad. My bad. I'm I'm getting a little too >> Think
about Let's think about what they're saying for a second and
see if there's any weight to this and, you know, we can have
a discussion there. But I think Willy's hardheaded. >> Wasn't
Wasn't your show often about a video comes out, there's a disagreement
with how it's done, and then creators hop on and and talk about
it? I mean, technicals is probably one of the best examples of
this. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah, 100%. >> Sula I think is
a horrible charact like characterization of the fight. That was
not what most of the fight was over. >> I mean that happened
all the time on uh you know in the old days but I think the climate
is much different nowadays. You know everyone's kind of in their
own community in their own circle on their own channel doing
their own thing. It's not like the old days anymore where, you
know, basically you had after hours, you know, Tommy C was also
doing his show or whatever, right? But basically, you had these
like live streams, you know, you had Doc on the radio where it
was just constant like open door policy. Yeah.
>> Good guy. He's a good guy.
>> Yeah. Um, but you know, you had these streams back in
the day that were just kind of open door programs where you know,
that was the content. But I think a big problem with that content
is it is kind of a pain in the ass for the creators to engage
in all the time. And so now everyone is sort of in their fortress
arc, which I'm not saying is even like a bad strategy or something.
It makes total sense to me.
>> I this is one thing uh again I had a conversation with
Quman briefly last night and um this is something I pointed out
is like dude, these people were all growing their channels like
gang busters off of their own content, their own like literally
just their the little universe they had going of personalities
and and like all it would have taken is just to come out and
go like yeah little L here, little L there. like, "Yeah, this
is I think that's good criticism." And we all like move on with
our days, right? I think that's all you had to do. And instead,
it was like, "I'm never making friends again. I'm never talking
to people again. This is totally we're all just fortressing up."
>> I think everyone's a little bit too uh sensitive when
it comes to criticism on their videos. And I feel like that's
pretty stupid. I don't know. Well, I I think that one of the
issues is that like maybe it feels one-sided sometimes because
streamers will criticize a video because I think Willie Mack
has said to >> Queen, "Yeah, we watch it in Xbox >> and
it almost I don't get to criticize you for your coverage." But
you can absolutely criticize a streamer for their coverage if
you want to. Um yeah, you know, I don't think you need to make
a video to make yourself subject to criticism. You just watch
a stream and go, they're wrong about this, they're wrong about
that. And um I don't know, man. I mean, is that not what it's
all about? Like criticizing each other? There's a lot of drama
comes off of this. But I think the problem from Willy's perspective
is honestly like he looks at these communities and he's like
engaging with this is just like it's not worth it for me because
they have the tiny audience, I have the bigger audience. It's
not even it's not like an equal I don't get nearly as much out
of engaging with this as they do with engaging with me. So from
his perspective, he's probably looking at it more like that where
he's like it's either out of like fear or it's out of, you know,
he just doesn't want to sort of constantly be bickering with
these smaller channels and stuff like that. That's probably where
he's coming from. >> You turn up. No, I can't do that.
cannot do that. >> Um yeah, I mean that that's fine like
you know logic don't want to pick with smaller channels but then
it seems a bit bizarre that you then make a video falsely claiming
that the smaller channel in my opinion falsely claim >> well
that's the problem. It's like if you're if you don't engage with
these people, just don't engage, right? But clearly he wants
to engage with them. But on his platform where he can, you know,
create the narrative for himself, post it to his channel, get
the 100,000 views because it's Hassan Slop and he can sort of
establish the narrative on these smaller creators uh and not
really have to he can't he doesn't even have to engage them anymore
because he's already painted them as malicious doxers. So therefore,
that's my out or whatever, right? I can just, you know, he wants
to engage them, but in a way where it's like a controlled environment
for him. >> Yeah, sure. Um Okay. So, >> I don't know.
>> What are your what is your sort of like responses, I
guess, or takes to Willy Max's comments in regards to you? Um,
you were friends, I thought. No. >> Yeah, we had a good
conversation, or at least I thought it was a good conversation
uh a month ago.
>> So, a month ago, Auggie and Lily Mack have a private
conversation where Willy Mack, I guess, it seems like, kind of
vents about me and Quan and a bunch. >> That's actually
the conversation he referenced in his video. You know, he mentioned
something about how first of all, I think Willie, I don't know
if he thinks that I am like cool or I just don't care that he
got doxed. I was disgusted when I found out that he got doxed.
I'm not just saying that's just a virtue signal right now. I
legit was like, "Wow, that really sucks." Like I didn't even
know what happened when it did happen. But yeah, Nick told me
like, "Yeah, Ben is running around with his docs and his wife
and stuff like that." And so I pulled up his Twitter and I looked
at it and I was like, "Wow, this is actually disgusting shit."
But you know, when I see somebody gets docks, I'm not just going
to like when am I supposed to tweet about it? You know, that's
just going to encourage people to look into it more. My logic
with Doc stuff is always ignore, ignore, ignore because the moment
you talk about it, you start drawing eyes to it and that's, you
know, that's opposite of what you want to do. >> That's
uh that's what a lot of people say. That was the standard back
in the day apparently. Just don't mention it, don't talk about
it, delete it if you see it. Like just take the oxygen away,
>> I mean, obviously I understand Woody Max probably, you
know, anxious the wedding stuff. I totally get that. I don't
have a problem with him talking about necessarily because the
wedding's done now. But there's also the mentality of like you
often don't want to draw attention to your own doc's information.
you want to kind of like ignore it as best as possible, too.
So, >> look, I can even excuse like I can even look at
it like, you know, Willie is obviously, you know, probably a
bit hysterical about the docks. He's probably a little bit emotional
and stuff like that. And so, >> it's fine for him to not
>> trying to get my compressor,
>> you know, completely 100% levelheaded. You know what
I mean? Like, obviously that's completely fine.
>> He is right lying. I mean, he created this video uh
on me or something, you know, he's lying saying that I basically
supported the docs and that I'm basically ganging up with a bunch
of people that are cryptodoxing him like Queen who's like dog
whistling calling for his docs, whatever the that means. Completely
taking their arguments totally out of context and just smearing
them. And okay,
the the Queenman thing was egregious. I will say the one thing
that like the one point he has is that Quimman had the video
on stream from the Destiny quote tweet that he was criticizing,
right?
He had that that that tweet on screen and it autoplayed while
muted and it looks to be censored if you're not paying close
attention and that's playing in the background, right? And he
said this in his statement earlier today is he didn't notice
it. And so what you would look for to tell if that's a dog whistle
is to see how he handled it after the fact, right? Well, he came
out and he said, "I don't want to do that stuff. I I removed
it instantly. I actually reached out to the Clipper channel and
said, "Hey, could you remove this? I really don't I don't want
this there. I don't want this with my voice there. Like, that's
[__] up, right?" He did everything he could. There
are other instances of Queenman stepping up and saying, "You
know what? This is this is wrong. I'm not going to allow this."
Uh when when Destiny's original logs with Lauren Southern got
released, okay, when they were originally being shopped, the
guy was in Quean's Discord and going like posting screenshots
and saying, "Look, look at look at what I got here. Look at what
I got here." Uh he offered it to Queman. He offered all of these
logs in a big dump to Quimman. Queman said, "I'm not going to
be leaking that [__] I don't want to leak that shit."
Right? And he didn't go with it. He didn't publish that [__]
He said, "No, no, no, no thank you. Don't post that here. I don't
want that my Discord. I don't want it dissociated with my Discord.
He deleted all of the images. He deleted all of the logs. Said
get the out of here. And Sunday was the person who broke those
DMs the first time. Right. Quan could have done it and he did
not. He is pretty he's had a pretty principled stance against
these kinds of privacy violations more or less the entire time
he's been streaming. He is not going to leak things. If things
become public information, he'll cover them, but he's not going
to leak things. And I like as a as a corollary of this, it's
just very unlikely that he was looking to do anything with Willy
Mack. And if he was gonna do it, he definitely wouldn't be doing
it in public on his stream. That would be crazy. And it's he
can get away with that because nobody likes Queenan, you know?
He can get away with that. I'm getting like so many people in
my comments and on Twitter basically being like, "You pile around
with these monsters. Like, what the like I I expected better
from you." He's painted it. He's basically painted them as many
bad empanadas. And so now everyone Oh.
>> So to Auggie, he was doing this way.
>> Consider the calling for his dogs, whatever the that
means.
Why I quit the internet for bad comments and on Twitter basically
being like >> all around with these monsters. Like what
the like I I expected better from you. He's painted he's basically
painted them as many bad empanadas. And so now everyone thinks
that I'm hanging out with bad empanada basically through this
video. And then that last part when he talks about like why I
quit the internet. First of all, I never told him that's why
I quit the internet. Now obviously the call that we had, he's
referencing a call we had a month ago where I called him trying
to ask him to debate Queen cuz I wanted to set up a debate on
my channel. So I Okay, that's crazy that you one. So what Willie
Mack does there when he leaks that what he does is he basically
says this thing where Auggie is getting harassed that super upset
him that puts a a target on Auggie's back immediately right that's
why you don't talk about this ever because anything you say can
be used as information that's why not commenting on doc stuff
is the best policy
right you just don't comment on it because anything you say can
be used against the person if you go oh he was really really
upset when this guy was trying to dox him yeah of course that's
going to [__] with him right of course that's going
to [__] with Auggie
You're basically telling that guy, "Hey, guy who was like unhinged
enough to try doxing this guy." By the way, I don't know. I don't
know the truth of any of those claims. I should just say right
off the bat that that like Salvo is trying to dox Auggie. I don't
know the truth. I remember there was something about Salvo driving
around trying to find Auggie's apartment, but I don't know about
like trying to dox him publicly or or like that. I'd have to
I'd have to figure that out. Okay. But you're basically signaling
out to somebody who is apparently unhinged enough to do this.
Like, hey, Auggie is really bothered. Augie is really bothered
by this. Yeah, we know who Mike David is. I called him. I was
just, right? I basically, it was half to like set up the debate,
but also half just to catch up with him and just see because
I hadn't talked to him in a while. And I So I call him or whatever.
And I'm like, "Hey man, like I want to do a debate between you
and Queen. Like I think this could be really fun." And he's obviously
giving me all of his reasons why he doesn't want to debate him.
And he's rattling off, you know, speaking like a thousand words
a second, talking about like how unfair they've been to him and
how they've like mistreated him and stuff like that. And he's
basically talking about how their communities have just been
a giant
pain in his ass. And so to relate with him cuz I'm talking to
him, I mention I'm like, "Yeah, I know what it feels like to
have communities go after you." And I mentioned like the salvo
thing and stuff like that to sort of, you know, let him know
that like, yeah, to empathize. So essentially, right, essentially
what happened here is Auggie talked to Willie and to empathize
with him, he went, "Yeah, unhinged people have come after me,
too." like it kind of it was like a stressful thing and I understand
where you're coming from, right? And Willie took that empathy
and weaponized it against Auggie in a video. Very cool. Very
based. Sounds like somebody here is a snake and it's not Chud
and it's not Auggie. Sounds like someone else here is the real
snake, right? Do you remember when uh when Willie and Tommy C
were leading into this like whole Chud is a snake thing? Chud's
trying to [__] people over. Yeah. It turns out every
accusation is projected. >> I get where you're coming from.
But then when he started explaining more and just going off,
you know, I start pushing back and questioning. I'm like, "Well,
how do these communities really engage in this sort of way? What
are your problems?" Blah blah blah blah blah. And he gets nervous
and he's like, "Dude, are you recording me?" And I'm like, "What
the hello?" So, I immediately start screen sharing to prove that
I wasn't cuz I'm like, "Dude, we're friends. Like, what do you
think? I'm taping you secretly and I'm going to give Queen in
the file so that he can review it the next day on stream. Why
would I do that?" Like, what the [__] But he got
very
>> So you heard that, right? Are you what are you recording
me right now? Wait, do you have any evidence of this? Do you
like know anything about this? Are you recording me? Are you
going to are you going to like go on clean stream in the back?
Uh, no. What? This is somebody who's like been his friend for
like a decade or like f five to eight years. 5 to 10 years. They've
been friends for and he's like thinking, "Oh, are you recording
me right now?" Because Auggie does a little tiny tiny little
bit of like, "Hey, maybe maybe is this are you sure this is true?"
>> You know, caught guard there at the idea that I was
recording him and I immediately had to like flip on my camera
and just be like, "Uh, no. I'm not a monster." Like, do you think
that >> Also, just to be clear, I have no idea how Auggie
turning his camera on proves that he's not recording via OBS.
I don't I don't get it. Was it like just to show your face and
be like, "No, we're friends, man. and you just wanted to talk
him down like he's a sh like he's a skittish horse. I don't even
know. >> Like but that's the level of paranoia that we're
dealing with here. You know what I mean? >> Well well I
I do know what you mean because I reached out to Willie M after
the first Destiny video. I showed the message of my own side
on stream and I just said you know hey man you're crashing out
on Twitter you're arguing with if you want to have a you know
a conversation I can explain the issues off stream if you want.
It could be recorded on your end for peace of mind. And then
he twisted that into I don't think he talked to Tommy C about
this and claimed there was some sort of snake for doing this
which I thought was weird because I don't really think it's snaky
to be like hey man let's have a combo about this issue you know
even off
>> So wonder if he's got this paranoia issue or something.
I don't know. >> Yeah I don't know. I think it just comes
down to this is probably his first time like dealing with the
Queenman and Jtocks. probably his first time dealing with like
somebody consistently talking [__] about him. That's
not >> Creamman could be very obnoxious.
>> Why is the audio being filtered? Um because I have a
compressor on and some of the white noise is catching up. So
it's compressing the voices so that Chud and Auggie is not so
separate. Okay, cuz otherwise Augie is like three times. >> We
got some I've got some some of his chatters can be very obnoxious,
too. We call them que beds. Okay, so I can understand being bothered
by that. But then it feels like he's letting it go way too far
into his head and it's bothering more than it needs to and now
he's created this narrative. They're all like doxing and which
just seems ridiculous or some of them are doxing. >> It's
like creating like all these like weird delusion. Like the only
way that I can accept that this video was not just like a malicious
just lie that he just made like just like me over personally
or whatever is oh it's going to be the empathy thing, right?
It's going to be like oh he's really upset. But you can't say
you're really upset and continue to double down, right? You can't
say, "Well, guys, I feel empathy for this guy and like and you
know, he was really upset and Willie comes out and goes, I'm
really upset." That that excuse only works if you like stop doing
damage. You can't say, "Oh, I was really upset because like my
wedding got doxed and that made me like make make bad decisions."
You can't say that after you've like quadrupled down. Okay? You
get to you get to use that when you make the original statement
that like I was amplifying your docs. Okay? You get to use that
like for a few days after that or you know maybe when you when
you first uh oh when you first get picked or get picked on Twitter.
Oh and and Auggie has to correct you on on retweeting the docs
or something, right? So he like he goes and like quote tweets
the some Destiny doxing thread, right? And so maybe you could
use it there, but you cannot use it like 3 weeks later when you've
not made any apologies. You've not said my bad anywhere, right?
You can't actually go and say now, "Oh, I was just upset over
my wife getting docks. I was just upset over my wedding getting
doxed. That doesn't work anymore. You've used up all that empathy
by being an as and just letting it sit there for weeks. >> It's
just that he's so delusional and hyper paranoid that he's not
trying to do that, but he's just doing that accidentally because
he's hurt or something like that. But I found it just very funny
that last point he made because it's very clear that he's projecting
honestly. you know, he wants to run this sort of narrative that,
you know, I went nuts and like left the internet or whatever,
right? Well, I mean, look at him right now. Look at how he's
responded to these people. You know what I mean? Like, it's very
clear that that's kind of what's he feels actually. And yeah,
I don't know. It's just uh the video was just worse than I could
have possibly imagined. I mean, I I'm trying to think of anything
else he said that was uh particularly egregious. It kind of just
all comes down to the fact that I think he thinks that I'm cool
with him being doxed, which I mean, I don't know how you could
come to that conclusion. That makes no sense. Um, and he plays
all these clips of me where I'm talking about like he plays that
one clip of me where I'm like, I don't think Queman has ever
celebrated or looked for your docs or anything like that or done
anything, you know, like that. And Willie plays that and then
he just like quit the internet. Like boom, mic drop without explaining
like uh >> uh if you really think that I guess you're just
really dumb and you should just if you're going to be this dumb
you should leave. You should leave actually. It's like do you
want to make any argument for why what he said was dumb or no?
I'm just going to mic drop now. >> No, actually here's
this clip of Queen being deranged. You're completely moronic
and incorrect here cuz if he had the clip then that's when you
can say quit the internet. You suck at your job. But he just
says you suck at your job without explaining why I'm wrong. And
there's another moment in the video that's exactly like that.
And it's like, uh, are you okay, bro? You are really
>> Yeah. So, so this was like you were basically blindsided
by this video. You were expecting him to come out and talk all
this about you from the sounds of >> Absolutely not. And
you know what's so funny? You messaged me uh that you were going
to do the stream and I didn't know cuz I don't use this disc
this like an old account of mine. Um, I don't use this Discord
account, right? And a lot of people still message me on this
account, not realistically that I have a different one. And so
I just like, you know, I opened this Discord up just to do this
call and I actually just saw
Willie Mack had sent me a DM from a day before I did my comeback
stream asking me if I wanted to play some video games. >> Oh
no. >> So apparently right before Auggie went live and
like did his whole I'm going to call Willie Mac stream, the day
before
Willie Mack asked him if you want to you want to come hang out,
you want to play some video games. Willy M tried to reach out
and Auggie wasn't on the right Discord account. Auggie, no. >> And
I'm like, oh, I if I had picked up that call, this would have
never >> Oh, wait, hang on. You're saying you would have
swept for the cab narrative. Is that what you're saying? >> Well,
no. We would have t I probably would have been like, "Hey, man.
I've seen your Twitter account." And we would have probably had
that conversation privately and I probably wouldn't have come
off that hard on stream the next day. But because I never saw
that, I was just spitting out what I was seeing. And that resulted
in this giant >> dude. Imagine Willie's mindset here where
like he sends that message and he feels like Auggie just ignores
it and then Auggie goes live the next day and just obliterates
him on stream. He's in that paranoid mindset, right? He's constructing
all of these enemies in the pit of his mind, okay? In the in
the shadowy pits of his mind. He's constructing enemies everywhere
and Auggie ignores him and then goes live the next day and just
trashes him. Oh my god, he's a part of the other Cabal now. He's
He's totally betrayed me. I have to do I have to do a video.
I have to do a video. Right. He just he I can just see it like
this explains so much that he feels like he reached out and Auggie
totally spurned him and now he's going to go li now he's going
to go make his own video totally on Auggie and he has to be completely
disingenuous to do it but it'll be worth it for I don't know
the reason. I have no idea why he thinks it would be a good idea.
I have no idea why he did it but he did Storm. So,
I mean, because let's be honest, >> real first. The cabal
is real. >> You know, >> bro, come on. I've been
those calls, man. I know what it's like. >> This is a No,
you're spinning it right now. You know, for you know damn well
if somebody's like playing if somebody wants to play video games
with you and you happen to like see them being crazy on Twitter,
you're like, "Yeah, sure. I'll play some games with you." And
also, while you're playing, you're going to be talking like,
"Hey, what's up? Like, I've seen your Twitter. Like, what's going
on there?" We probably would have talked about it, you know,
and this would have never happened. But I didn't see the message.
So >> Oh no, dude. >> So now over.
It's not been more over for you, has it? >> But to be honest,
I'm glad that this happened because I've seen his nature. You
know what I mean? I've seen cuz he's clearly malicious now. I
mean, that's >> he's seen he's seen his nature. Okay. He's
seen the
the Irishman within. Okay. The sneaky Irishman. I don't know
if I'm like hyper stab anybody in the back, but I think it's
clear that, >> you know, he will he will get very nasty
with you if uh you perturb him in any sort of way. >> And
sure, he's going after targets like Queenman and Jay-to easy
to hate. I guess maybe I'm easy to hate. I'm not really sure.
But, you know, he has shown that he's capable of doing this really
to anyone that upsets him. You know, I mean, this is just Is
it wrong to say that this video is just complete lies, malicious
smears?
>> You know, I would be willing to engage the idea that
Queen or JTO were both the doxers or they, you know, host doxing
or they allow doxing if there's any >> Listen, Willie just
hated us from day one. Okay? Nothing can be done. >> But
there's no evidence in the video. So, I'm a bit like, okay, >> show
me cuz I want to know. You know, I've been on I've been on Jtock
stream. I've interacted with Quimman. If I'm accidentally buddying
up, which by the way, I love this idea that you're buddying up
with somebody just because you talked to them once or twice,
right? But if I'm buddying up with these people, show me the
harmful [__] that they do that's not just or just
show where we're like wrong about something we're saying after
the fact, right?
Like just show where like we're we're totally unhinged towards
them. Show anything.
Show anything.
The best people can do is go, "Oh, you're like attached to these
other people.
to me cuz it's like okay well we're commentary YouTubers right
we're as to everybody if somebody's an assh you like I can you
know I can be like well that's not great you know that's my friend
I don't like seeing people be mean to them or whatever right
but if you're going to tell me that this is like a dangerous
community to be around well you got to show me what you're talking
about you can't just
you know give me this hysterical
retelling of your last eight months you know which basically
just boils down to them making criticisms of >> Yeah. I
mean, it it does feel like there has a loss of this kind of like
let's just hop on stream and talk about it mentality that even
I experienced back in the day where we'd have like panels, people
would come on, we'd all talk. >> The audio is not that
bad. Hold on. I hold on. I'll just I can fix the audio. Maybe
it's better without the compressor. We'll just we'll refresh.
>> Come on, we'll talk and stuff like that. >> You
know, that all seems to have kind of gone by the wayside now.
And I I can see because I've I've at times been like, okay, like
you know, I can understand the audience is very fer fervor there.
They want a lot of blood and stuff like that. So maybe you don't
want to have a conversation on stream, but it just seems like
now it's like there's no conversations between commentary people
ever. It's all on your stream and that's about it. >> Look,
there's there's got to be a balance. You know what I mean? I
obviously get it. It's it's obnoxious. Like anytime you give
a take on stream, well, debate me on this or whatever, right?
It's obnoxious to be in that loop where you have to sort of,
you know, waste your time like having these endless arguments
or something like that sometimes. But in general, I think, yeah,
when it comes down to it, Quean is has disagreements with Willie
and he wants to engage, right? Willie has disagreements with
Quean and clearly Willie wants to engage because Willie engages
with them on Twitter and on his YouTube channel all the time,
right? M. So just at that point, you can't just sit there and
say, "Well, I'm just going to ignore them and just do >> Willie
wants to engage. He just doesn't want anybody to disagree with
him in the moment. He wants to be able to paint a narrative.
He doesn't want any opposition to it. That's all any of these
people want, right? They just want to be able to paint a narrative
with no opposition. I'm totally fine if somebody has like a a
major problem with me. I'm totally fine discussing like my takes
on the stream, right? You want to dig into my personal life,
that's different. I'm probably not going to discuss that with
you. But if all you want to do is just have a conversation about
some take I gave on stream like about your content, hop on the
stream. It's totally fine cuz you're not ignoring them and you're
not doing your own thing. So now you just look like a [__]
because you know it's either don't respond to them at all, never
address them again, or you know, engage with them. And I don't
know. >> Yeah, sure. Um, dude, this is difficult because
obviously I like to, you know, I like to have disagreements normally
when I speak to people, but I think we've got a lot of similar
views on this. I mean, you know, I didn't really, to be honest
with you, mate, I'm a bit out of all of this. I feel a bit on
the outside now cuz apparently everyone hates me in this commentary
[__] >> I'm shocked you I'm shocked you covered
this cuz I've noticed Yeah. for a while. I think after the Tommy
Sea war, I noticed you've kind of just been in your own lane
recently. Like I haven't really heard from you. >> So,
I'm surprised you covered this. The the thing is for me, I I
genuinely am not super interested in this intro commentary stuff.
I do feel like I just want to do my own thing primarily. But
when I saw the video, I was just kind of outraged. I was like,
"This is too much, man. This is like completely outlandish being
said." Am I >> I will say this exact outlandish
was said by Destiny like 3 4 days ago. Destiny's been running
this narrative. I don't know. I don't know why people are like
It's just one of those things where it's like we don't call it
the principles really. we call out. Not that I'm not saying Chud
could be totally unaware of this, but for me it's like a lot
of people would have to be aware of this. I know I started calling
it out, but of course when I call it out, it's like Eerite saying
that like, oh, me and Queen are responsible for doxing her or
swatting her or something, right? So obviously a ton of DJs flood
those comments. It just doesn't get any traction. But like it's
been happening for a while now. We're in like the second week
of this where where Destiny's just trying to blatantly with no
evidence whatsoever blame Queen and I for things Kiwi Farms does.
concern is that because people hate Queman and JTalk that people
are just going to go like crazy at it and act like, "Yep, this
proves Queen and Jaystalk are dogs." And it's like, well, it
doesn't prove that at all, you know? So, it just felt like, >> might
as well go live and just give my my take on it all. So, >> yeah.
Well, I'm glad you're covering it, man, cuz it's pretty much
an uphill
>> He's kind of put he's kind of put me in a weird situation
here. So, um Yeah. Well, yeah, cuz your your community is still
there, but you kind of obviously don't stream as much anymore.
So, you don't have as much of a platform, I don't think, to really
defend yourself. >> Yeah, this got a huge platform. >> Less
about that. I still get good numbers when I stream, but more
so just like I feel like I'm the only one in my neck of the woods
that's going to cover
>> So, and I also feel like I'm the only one in my neck
of the woods that's going to cover this >> from my perspective.
You know what I mean? So, it's a little bit of an uphill battle,
but I mean, I'm going to go live and cover it. And I'm gonna
be fair and I'm gonna be honest and if Willie Mack wants to come
on, I [__] would love to >> Willy. So Willie
has been going on shows doing commentary today. He went on Hutch's
channel, right, with a positive interview. Will Willie go and
have a conversation with Auggie, a potentially contentious conversation,
or is he going to cower like a [__]
That's the question. It's really a rhetorical question because
we know he's going to cower like a [__] >> You
know, I'd love to challenge him on this because I think that
his video >> Oh, sure. Yeah, Nick for not covering it is
also a [__] Yeah, absolutely. >> Fair. Okay.
Um, yeah. Well, anyway, that's that's about it really. That's
about all I've got to say about that. Um, anything else you want
to cover before we >> I think that is it. >> I might
do some Chud coverage after this, but unfortunately, guys, we're
missing we're missing critical content right now. We watched
the Auggie interview.
Now, we need the Auggie stream. Okay, Auggie has started responding
as of 52 minutes ago.
things about me that I have no s >> We've got we've got
an Auggie response. Okay, big things happening. >> Lying
and spirit, not just me, but a couple other people >> claiming
that we justified uh his docks.
It's pretty much the main claim is that we justified his docs.
He said a lot of nasty things about me, that I have no sympathy
for him, that uh
here I'm just adjusting my audio. He said I don't have any sympathy
for him getting doxed. He uh leaked private conversations
>> 1567
has become a channel member
against me. People are saying, "Wait, what?" Yeah, I guess if
you're not on Twitter, you have no context as to what's happening.
But uh yeah, Willie Max show is very, very, very upset with me.
And he put out this video. It was disguised as like a bad empanada
video. And to be fair, he does talk a lot about bad empanada,
a lot of stuff with Kraut and tea and stuff like that.
Um, but he spends a lot of time talking about me, talked about
my last section that I did on him. >> Has become a channel
member >> and it's absolutely
crazy. So, we're going to go live. It's going to be a bit of
a shorter stream cuz I'm just mainly just going to address this
just cuz I kind of have to. Lot of people are curious on what
I had to say about this. I did call into Chudlogic's show earlier
and sort of expressed my sort of free form thoughts on this whole
thing,
but we're going to do a proper live dissection of the whole video
of the whole video. >> Dioro's days are numbered. >> Okay.
And I see a lot of people asking me thoughts on Dioro not talking
about >> H. It's so it's so but it's it sucks but it doesn't
suck but it's ah >> this look here's the thing. Dioro called
me last. Nicholas Nicholas had a bit of a issue today on Twitter.
We could maybe get into that a little bit later. The It's so
funny because if you guys don't know who this Alex Gekkmo guy
is, okay, there's this Eggids guy on Twitter who's basically
like he's just like trolls in the commentary community. He people
he criticizes them, right? And Nicholas said like the death nail
the death nail for for Boaxs was Boax trying to pick a fight
with this guy. And today Nicholas went and actually just blocked.
Okay, actually just blocked Alex Gekkmo. Okay, this guy Alex
Gekko was his biggest like friend, his biggest ally. Biggest
not biggest friend, biggest ally in like that space. Alex liked
him and Alex is disgusted by what he sees. All right. Blocked
him today. Wow. And he's just he's pure he's wall to-wall anti
Nicholas coverage right now. >> Sad to see. last night
and he told me two things which is that one of which is that
hey I didn't know that Willie was going to do this to you
was like I had no idea Willie was making this video just to be
clear this isn't like some like oh they're talking about you
behind the scenes and planning on you over this is at least as
far as Dioro knows this is all Willie this is all in Willy's
>> oh so there's more leaking Nicholas does not think that
Willie has any proof. Willie just think Nick thinks Willy's like
deranged. Okay. I like Listen, I like leaks like that cuz obviously
now if Nick really disagreed with that, he could come out and
say so. Yes. Like it sucks that Nick's not going to say anything,
but Auggie just throws that out there. Nick might not like it,
but he just throws it out there like, "Hey, Nick thinks you're
crazy." And if Nick is going to disagree and say you're not crazy,
then he can come out with evidence of his own. >> Member
TM celebrates 12 months of membership. Willie is the next yearly
commentary [__] to get exiled from the community.
Tommy is next. >> Well, I don't think that's going to happen.
Um, so yeah. >> By the way, I will just say it's it every
single time I think back on like the private conversations that
I had with Nicholas and Queman, they're so funny to me because
I just kept telling telling Nicholas over and over again, you
know, he's going to kill all your friends, right? You know he
hates all your friends. Like all your friends are and they they're
all dumb. They're all going to get killed, right? It was it was
Boax.
Who else is it? It was Boax. lyrics to some extent. Tommy C and
now now Willie, they're all gonna die. >> Yeah. So Nick
told me >> I told him I told him Queen was like Hannibal.
Okay. He's like, you ever seen the Hannibal show on TV? Queen's
like going to sit there and he's going to like smile and shake
your hand and then you're going to find out that he just fed
you your like best friend's leg the other day. Okay,
Nicholas. Tonight Nicholas is dining on the the spleen of Willie
Mac. Okay. And he doesn't even realize it. >> One thing
which is that he didn't know that Willie was going to make this
video on me. Um, and he also told me that he's not planning on
covering this, right? Which I mean, I knew exactly what was going
to happen. This was going to infuriate the community. I guess
a lot of people are wondering if >> community has become
a member. >> And the truth is is like, look, I I don't
want to It's It puts me in a weird position because I don't want
to be in this weird position. >> Who are you in this analogy?
Uh, who am I in this analogy? I assume I'm Will. Okay. I assume
I'm the person with empathy who's like, "You should be better.
You should be better."
Is it It's It's going to seem like at some point that I'm going
to turn against Qu. We're going to be on opposite sides, okay?
And then in the end, we'll like kill that guy together. All right.
That's how it's going to go. >> I'm like, "No, Nick, you
have to cover this." Because it looks like I'm basically saying,
"Nick, you got to save me. You got to [__] save my
ass." Like Willie stomped on me. Like, please, Nick, please help
me and save me from this whole situation. It's like I can cover
this on my own. I don't really need other people to fight my
battles for me. Um, but I completely understand why people are
upset that he's not covering it because at the end of the day,
I mean, Willie did this video. >> At what point is Auggie
going to disable his alerts? Okay, Auggie, please, for the love
of God, disable your alerts for a little bit. You're going to
have a lot of members joining. You're going to have a lot of
people hopping on this stream cuz it's big drama. Turn the alerts
off, okay? And just Yeah, >> it was very bad. This video
is very bad. It is pretty I I'm pretty comfortable saying this
video is completely malicious. I mean, he outright lies about
so many people and their arguments, their intentions. I mean,
we'll play the video, the full thing. We're not skipping a beat
with this video, but Willie is like, >> "Oh, he's going
to watch the whole >> Way off the deep end. And I've seen
a lot of people in this community say that I've gone off the
deep end, but because I'm not fine with smearing people. >> That's
what we consider going off the deep end because I'm not f I'm
not okay with smearing and J as dirty doctors and doing Destiny's
dirty work.
>> Oh,
let's go. you know, celebrating and uh rebroadcasting his propaganda.
>> He's willing he's willing to name this predator. Okay,
he's willing to name him >> that he's putting on all of
his enemies saying that everyone that has an issue with him is
an evil dirty doxer while providing no proof for that because
I have an issue with that. That means that I'm, you know,
>> I'm going to mute these notives just cuz I I got a lot
to say and I don't want these things just like irritating the
>> Hold on. Hold on. Oh, he won't do that.
Wrong. Wrong. He will he will mute it cuz he wants to actually
speak.
>> It's like we're going to sit here and really act like
I'm the irrational one because I'm not cool with just smearing.
But it's like we're going to sit here. >> Yeah. Scary Terry
says, "Yeah, being on Queen's side is crazy." >> I really
act like I'm the irrational one because I'm not cool with just
>> No, people are mad because Queman is massively disingenuous.
All these people have to do is hop on the stream. All you got
to do hop on the stream. All you have to Just hop on the stream,
bro. just hop on the train, get in the >> because they
some of my friends off. >> Okay, because that's what I'm
starting to notice is going on in this community. People are
getting way too comfortable lying and just telling stories that
just aren't true about people that they don't like, including
people that have done things towards them. I understand why Tommy
C is mad at these people. I get why Willy's mad at these people,
but I'm not cool suddenly with just lying about them, you know,
and and especially I'm not cool with rebroadcasting Destiny's
narratives that anyone that goes after him is part of Queen and
J's doxing communities when he has no evidence except for one
guy that was caught sharing a doc that was immediately banned
as soon as Desi called. Just to be clear, that one guy, it doesn't
mean anything cuz that guy was banned as soon as they found out
about it. But that one guy was in Chud's Discord technically.
Okay, that's I'll just say that one guy that was in Chud's Discord,
not indicative of Chud's Discord's character or anything like
that, and they banned him when they found out, but literally
the one guy they had to try to prove something wasn't even a
part of our >> That guy out. I'm not going to rebroadcast
lies and things that I know aren't true, okay? I'm just never
going to do that. And so, anyone sitting here thinking that I
got blown the out, well, I'm curious what your opinion is going
to be once we once we finish watching this because this video
is a load of stinking [__] This video is just I mean
not to just to be clear, not the whole thing. The parts where
he says bad Epanata is an horrible doxer. That's true. Bad Epanata
is a horrible doxer. Bad empanada docks with Willie Mack and
his wife. We don't like that. In fact, I was disgusted obviously.
I mean, do I have to [__] say it? Obviously,
>> that bad empanada was doxing life and trying to make
their wedding hell. >> We were all disgusted. We all hate
that. Okay, we all hate that. Nobody wants to, dude. Oh, and
I have every reason to like hate Willie, okay? I have every reason
to hate this guy, but like nobody wants like Yeah, it's like
a whole other person. Somebody wants to spend their life with
Willie. I have no idea what he's like. Like when he's not being
a loser on the internet and being incapable of reading, okay,
for all I know, that woman is his caretaker. She's the reason
that he can get up in the morning and put his clothes on. All
right, I don't want anything bad to happen to her. >> Okay,
obviously. But here's the thing, right? I'm not going to [__]
go on Twitter or go on my show and say, "Oh my god, bada doxed
Willie. Guys, this is terrible because one, that doesn't need
to be said, but two, that just brings more attention to the docks.
If I go on the air and I'm sitting here telling everyone, "Guys,
did you see Pata dox Willie? That's horrible."
One, that's a worthless opinion because it should be obvious
that I think all doxing is horrible, so it's just a waste of
time to even say that. But two, I'm hurting Willie in the process.
I'm making people more aware of it so that anyone that's watching
my streams that doesn't really give a about me or Willie is like,
"Oh, really? Willy's information is out there?" Oh, well, thanks.
Thanks, Auggie for letting me know where exactly I can go to
find it, you know? So, it just makes no sense, >> dude.
The the crazy thing here is is going to be when Auggie gets to
the part, okay, Augie is going to get to the part of this video
that the tweet the tweets weren't out there yet cuz Destiny hadn't
watched the video. He's going to get to the part of the video
where Willie goes, "Felt really good to have Destiny come out
and defend me. You know, somebody I criticize comes out and defend
me. Defends me. Felt really good when Destiny spread my docs.
It's like then you have the clip from Destiny today. I don't
give a [__] I'm gonna [__] Will, but
I don't give a [__] I'm dox and all these people.
It's like I don't I'm going after all these people now. Everything's
out there. It's like okay, so you didn't think about Willie at
all. Okay, cool. >> So, obviously this video like the parts
that he attacks bad empanada on for the most part from what I
can tell seems fair to me. Seems fair. It seems accurate. It
seems great. Here's the problem though. We're not just calling
out bad empanada. This is not just a bad empanada video. Willie
has to include other targets, other people that have been him
off for months now. People that have been really getting under
really grinding Willy's gears. He's now comfortable with smearing
them and throwing them under the bat empanada umbrella, acting
like they have any part in this while also showing no evidence
that they do. The arguments he makes in this video are laughable.
And trust me, okay, he criticized me for not watching the original
video that picked him off. We're going to watch it.
But I think uh you know I can just sit here and just yap or whatever,
right? But we might as well just play it. And like I said, I'll
play the whole thing. Okay. Now, I'm mainly interested in the
valid targets section of the video. But I'll play the whole thing.
Whatever. Let's do it.
>> Alex and Chess says he has to include Destiny's enemies
and spread Destiny's narrative. Yeah, exactly. And he's going
to get into it like why I uh I think he's upset that I suggested
that he might be controlled opposition. I'll get into that too
because I have a very clear and obvious argument to make as to
why I said on my last show that either Willy's or his controlled
opposition and then I saw Tommy C covering this today. I I didn't
watch all of his coverage, but I tuned in a little bit. >> Dude,
Tommy C covered this, too. >> Watching this video. >> God
damn. >> Confused. Tommy C's watching this video and he's
sitting there. He's like, Auggie, if you're going to call him
controlled opposition, you have to prove it. And it's like, Tommy,
in the context of the argument that I'm making, it's very clear
what I'm saying. I mean, wouldn't you just say for Destiny's
first video, he got info for that video from like Not So Erdite
directly? Isn't that Isn't that like already kind of weird? Like
not disclosing that? Like, hey, I went to Destiny's business
partner to get this info about Sunday. Isn't that odd? Isn't
it odd? Like, wouldn't you want to know? Like, were there any
other comments? I And maybe there weren't. It just feels a little
strange to me that he got like info from Arerodite for that video.
Just seems a little a little off just to me personally. We'll
get into that. Trust me, we'll get into that. But anyway, let's
just start the video. Why not? >> All right. All right.
Sorry. Sorry. We're going to normal speed this. >> Better
is a known doxer and harasser. If you go on his Twitter account
at any time, you can see him doxing people. He's probably the
most famous for being the one who claimed he called CPS on Ethan
and Hila. He's constantly encouraged and defended people doing
it. He literally opened up a CPS merch line because he thinks
it's so funny. >> Got a hat. I did CPS. The CPS logo with
the two skulls. Of course, two skulls not a reference to anything
in >> He knowingly defames people. In my last video, I
pointed out at bad empanada constantly claims that loner box
is dead was part of >> Okay, I'm uh I'm probably going
to skip through the bad empanada bad stuff. Okay, we know bad
empanada bad empanada very bad. Let me see if uh >> against
his opponents he just [__] up every single time.
I I I don't think I've seen a single Hassan clip recently that's
impressed me or made me think like haha that's a base Hassan
moment, >> you know? So, I'll just be clear because I know
a lot of people random people, right? He has found the perfect
tool, the perfect weapon. this stupid [__] war so
that he can sit there and morally justify why he's allowed to
just completely [__] [__] up and make
heinous lies about people and dox people and spread it all around,
you know. >> Okay, that that'll be more about he's an attention
seeking troll. >> Oh, sorry. No, no, no. >> For example,
I can tell you that the YouTuber Zuma historian history YouTuber
is this guy. I can tell you this because it is within journalistic
interest to do so even though he did not release his information
himself publicly just like how I can tell you that Willie Mau
is William McConville and um he is getting married to Yale. Now,
I am not going to give you the full name of um the person he's
getting married to. >> He literally just scrolled down
and showed her full name. I reported the video and he added this
little blur, but it still doesn't cover her name. >> She
is Israeli and she was assigned to him by the Israeli government.
They've taken down this page, but as you can see, it is freely
available on Google. They for some reason, as the guy who is
a public figure, decided to just publicly announce in public
his wedding. >> How is this allowed on YouTube? He does
this thing where he constantly tries to justify his reason for
doxing me. He's like, "Ethan docs Denim when he sued >> This
guy has no right to complain about revealing his real name to
be
show, which is a podcast that frequently docks. In Ethan's recent
video talking about his uh lawsuit against three young women,
he included redacted legal legal filings that he made that include
their real names and their real legal filings. >> Unfortunately,
I got I can cut this context out. We've already watched the video.
I just I
did correct
them. He caused it. Give me two seconds. I can't imagine going
through this if I was Billy. And I do genuinely have sympathy
for him obviously right now when he comes out of nowhere with
these like but my wife's seen the news. She's seen like these
two Israeli embassy people that got it's like okay. I mean I
understand the argument. I don't know if you need to say that.
That's just I'm so extra. But okay, I see where he's going with
this and he's right. Sure. This is the clip. You're done, buddy.
I'm sorry, dude. I just have to be honest, dude. I'm reacting
honestly to this [__] I'm not saying he's wrong.
Okay, I'm not saying that. Come on. Let's be adults here. >> Saw
two low-level staffers at the Israeli embassy get shot and she's
worried. So, I'm being told by the police that I should go online
and see if there's any direct threats. And I see a video made
by a guy who hates me showing all of my information and giving
a hypothetical where I'm a valid target. Okay, here's the part
of the video where we go crazy. So, again, we're at 6 minutes
30. Everything I've seen so far has been pretty reasonable in
my opinion, right? It seems fair. It's reasonable. It's correct.
It's valid. It's fine for him to go after Badonata is actually
good and based that he's going after Banana. Badanata is a bad
guy. Badanata is a for what he did to Willie. We're all in agreement
here. Okay, here's where we start to get [__] nutty.
Okay, >> so I'm being told by the police that I should
go online and see if there's any direct threats. and I see a
video made by a guy who hates me and showing all of my information
and giving a hypothetical where I'm a valid target because destiny's
a hypocrite. >> TV said anything involving this bad empanada
guy or anyone that supports him is justifiable. Anything is justified
against bad empanada and anyone that supports him. Let's apply
those standards. Why are we saying this about bad empanada? Well,
it appears to be because bad empanada docks will max. So,
okay. I just wanted to throw it out here, guys. Um had a good
monologue where he calls out not just um not just Willie, but
he calls out Nicholas Dioro as well. I think we will cover that
if Auggie doesn't get to it. All right. If we if we don't get
to that, we'll cover that as well. >> Would Destiny be
saying that those who dox people, those who make calls to violence
or illusions to violence should be fair game? And all of their
supporters, all the personalities that back him up, all the chats
that back him >> This is essentially a Destiny snark community,
this guy's narrative for the past six months, is that I'm covering
for Destiny, despite me making two of the most in-depth videos.
>> Okay. Okay. Hold on. Before we get into that, let's
just watch the full segment here. Because right off the bat,
what Willy's implying here is that Quimman is making an argument
to sort of justify doing whatever you want to not just Destiny,
but all of his supporters. Is that what said is Quan going on
streams making justifications and rationalizations for why? If
you haven't seen this, I I tweeted this out uh as well. I tweeted
a different one that was only cry cropped to Queen's camera,
but like if you haven't seen this, it's very obvious what Queen
does. Queman comes in and he goes, "The standard Destiny is proposing
here that you can do anything to ban Panata now and his supporters
is laughable because that standard obviously applies to anybody
around him. He is literally through his standard justifying everything
that happens around him. He cannot be upset about it. He is justifying
it and that's crazy. That's not my standard, but that is the
standard he proposes, right?"
And people go, "Oh, so you're saying it's okay to attack us?"
No, I'm saying Destiny is saying that.
It's not even a hypothetical. Willie at some point here says
it's a hypothetical, right? It's not a hypothetical.
It is the standard Destiny is saying is his actual standard in
reality. It's not a hypothetical at all. They're allowed to be
a complete deranged maniac towards Destiny and his supporters,
which they believe Willie Mac is. Right. Willie criticizes me
in this video for not watching the full queen and clip. I didn't
know I needed to because I thought the argument he was making
was just brain dead obvious, but okay, whatever. Let's watch
the full clip. This is posted
uh this was posted well this is like a different version of the
clip. This is weeks ago at this point. Let's watch it. And people
in chat are saying so people in chat right now that think I'm
a prick that think I'm an that think I'm team Hassan that think
I am pro Willy Mack getting doxed are saying in the chat right
now is literally dog whistling to go with Willie. Okay, that's
a big claim. So let's watch Queenman's clip and see if that's
actually what's happening. >> Actually my dad said he would
he
as well. Oh, I've got this
fast. >> Let's play this at one. >> He's got it going
a little fast.
>> Quimman's not even making a hypocrisy argument. Quuman
is saying that your standard is insane. He's not saying you're
a hypocrite. Destiny is just doxing people, right? He is doing
that. It's not a hypocrisy argument even. It's hey, you have
to understand that this has to this has to raise alarm bells
for anybody in Destiny's audience. Oh, he's literally justifying
people attacking me. That is what Destiny is doing when he says
this. Any act against bad empanada based on this docs is justified
right now. I'm sure Destiny would argue, well, there's way more
packed in there, right? That that bad empanada has done other
stuff, too. Calls for violence, basically. Here are the the arguments
against bad empata. He calls for violence. He doxes people, right?
Those are like the the major things I've seen. Destiny calls
has called for violence against me. Destiny's called for violence
against Quean. He's tried to dox both me and Quimman.
Okay. So, we got both elements there. Okay. Now, anything done
to Destiny by Destiny standard, not mine. Obviously, by Destiny's
standard, all of his supporters, anybody around him is now a
valid target. That that is the standard he's putting out in the
world, right? >> Actually, uh uh called for my death, said
he he would he would kill me. Uh there is actually a moment in
this video. It shows Destiny attempting to dox me as well. Obviously,
I'm not the >> So, Destiny said he wants to kill Queen.
He wants to dox Queen. He wants to do all this horrible [__]
to Queen. Kind of sounds like bad empanada stuff. I don't know
if Willie has any comments about that,
but okay, let's keep watching. >> Only person this has
happened to. Now, a little interesting. I saw someone tweet out
a fellow by the name of Little Little Steve tweeted something
very interesting out. >> Oh, what did Stevie tweet? >> Little
Steve? >> What did he tweet? What is he doing? >> What
is he talking about? TV said
anything involving this bad empanada guy or anyone that supports
him is
Anything is justified against bad empanada and anyone that supports
him.
>> Well,
let's apply those standards. Why are we saying this about Bad
Empanada? Well, it appears to be because Bad Empanada docked
Willie Mac's wife. So would Destiny be saying that those who
>> dox people, those who make calls to violence or illusions
to violence
should be fair game. And all of their supporters and all of their
supporters, okay? All the personalities that back him up, all
the chatters that back him up, everything are just everything
against these people. Anything is justifiable. That seems to
be the standard to me is that anything is just
>> Oh, anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Super appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. >> And the people who
support him. No. Is that not the standard? That's that's what
he's laying out for me here. Now, I have principles. I have principles.
I don't think it's no bad tactics, only bad targets. That's not
me. >> Okay. So Quimman's making a very simple argument,
right? Which is that Destiny engages in the same bad behavior
that bad empanada does. Now let's be clear. I think bad empanada
is much much much worse and more evil than Destiny. Okay, let
me just be clear here. But a lot of the things bad empanada does
on a regular bas
here for Auggie, not that I want to criticize Auggie, would just
be I would just want to ask Auggie, hey, like based on what?
Based on based on what? Like I, by the way, I think because of
the things I'm aware of that that's true, but I don't think I
can make that claim in like this current world. I don't know
if I can make that claim because I'm aware of everything bad
Destiny has done. I'm not aware of the bad stuff Bad Empanad's
done. And I'm a little more sensitive given the accusations Destiny
and his community and people around him throw around. I'm a little
more aware of how without knowledge, you know, saying that I
think this happened just based on hearsay probably not a good
idea. >> Is this is behavior that Destiny is starting to
do especially a lot more frequently. I will say amplifying the
the wedding tweet I that's
>> I but do we think Destiny would or wouldn't do that?
I don't know. >> Right. So when Destiny makes moralizing
statements like anything
>> uh involving this bad empanada guy or anyone that supports
him is justifiable.
>> What is saying
about him because he engages in the same [__] right?
But then he follows it up with saying but that's not my standard.
That's the standard that Destiny is
>> that's not my standard, but you could say that about
him.
Very simple argument to follow. Let's keep watching the clip
because >> dude, there are some people who just struggle
with this so badly on Twitter. I retweeted or I I tweeted my
own version of this clip and there are some people who are like,
"But he said it's okay to attack Will Maxel cuz he like Destiny."
I was like, "No, no, he didn't. He didn't say that was okay.
No, >> Something happens.
>> Oh, that's not me. But Destiny is very clearly laying
out that those are the standards that he believes in. Those are
the standards he he wishes to be enforced. Is if you're a doer,
if you call for violence, anything is justifiable against you
supporters. >> Order taken. >> So, somebody donates,
one of Quean's fans donates. It says,
>> "Got it. Order taken." They're either making a joke
or they're saying, "Oh, haha, I understand the dog whistle, blah,
blah, blah." And then Queenman >> "Okay, that's not why
I'm saying Max. Actually, I just explicitly said otherwise."
Actually, Max, >> he says, "No, that's Max Striker. Max
likes to donate things like edgy things like that just to catch
people off guard." Okay, that's something he does very regularly.
Does it all the time. We all know Max. Max comes here sometimes,
says edgy things. Max comes here and says, "Hey, do you want
to talk about like aparthide in South Africa or something?" I
don't know. He says like he I can tell he's trying to bait me
into having a race-based conversation, and I'm like, "No, I'm
I don't know about that. I don't really know much about, you
know, no. >> That's just how Max is. >> That's not
what I'm saying. Just to be clear here, right?
>> no, Max doesn't need to die. Max is fine. Max just likes
to meme. >> He's making the mortal sin here of grinning
and laughing. He's making the mortal sin of grinning and laughing,
>> which is an actual >> This is actually disgusting
>> as evidence that this whole entire video clip is a whistle
>> because Queen grinned and laughed at somebody saying
something up. That means that Queman is signaling to his chat,
"Haha, you guys get it, right?" And that's the argument that
we're making. And that's the argument that really this whole
section of Way's video rides off of. That's the argument that
we're going off of here is that this video is a dog
So, as we always say guys with dog whistles, what do you need
to do when you hear a dog whistle? It is the answer is ask a
question or look at prior behavior, right? For an indication,
where is the prior behavior of Queenman trying to dox anybody
trying to violate people's privacy even, right? Like where is
the prior behavior of him trying to dox?
Where is the prior behavior of him? Uh, I mean trying to dox
or sorry, where or where? Ask him a question. That's it. Ask
a question. Prior behavior. So, there is no prior behavior. And
you haven't asked him a question or even nobody's asked him the
question, but Queen has outright stated, "I did not mean to do
this. I didn't realize the video was playing. I didn't realize
how much information was shown. I thought it was censored. As
soon as I was made aware, I removed it." Right? So, on the ask
part, you fail. And on the prior behavior part, you fail. making
this allegation given he denies it and he's taken steps to try
to prevent your dogs from going any further and on the fact that
sorry and on the fact that there's no prior behavior. That's
the one. There's no prior behavior. Sorry, I didn't write any
of this out. So, I'm I usually write stuff out when I want to
make um any arguments like this. I I haven't written it down
at all. So, because of that, you can't really say anything. There's
uh one other thing, too. I'll think of it later. We'll just keep
going for now. >> And a tacit endorsement. >> Focus
up. I am focused up. I'm just sorry. I'm uh >> of doing
>> I'm reading comments and [__] It's my >> Destiny
and all of Destiny,
>> which includes Willie.
>> That is the good faith interpretation
of Willy's argument.
Well, I'm sorry, dude.
>> But I think that that's
paranoid, schizophrenic, and I just cannot for the life of me
watch this clip and sit here and act like that's a good [__]
argument. Okay, >> I just want to make it clear that Not
so
uh, Not So Aerodite, Destiny,
anybody in Destiny's community,
uh, who else? And Willy Mack, all of these people are intentionally
protecting doxers to make this claim. They are saying they're
they don't have proof or they have proof and they're hiding it.
So either they're maliciously lying, right? Knowing they have
no proof, they're fabricating this entirely, or they are protecting
doxers intentionally to make this allegation, right? Because
what what we would do if they told us, "Hey, here's somebody
who is in your community and they like dox people is we would
just ban that person, right?" So, so one of two possibilities,
fabricated whole cloth or they're somehow aware of a connection
to some skitso on an anonymous forum and our community and they
refuse to tell us about it so they can continue to make this
claim. Why? And I assume that they'd say, "Well, we're not fabricating
at whole cloth. So why then are they protecting these people?
That's the only other option. You're hiding the evidence you
have so as to not like warn us or so you could keep trying to
maliciously smear us. You're either fabricating whole cloth or
you're acting maliciously anyway. There's no good option. There's
no good faith option here outside of
>> Okay, if somebody comes into my chat, let's say somebody
comes in my chat right now and is like, I'm going to blow up
Willie Mac with a bomb or something, right? And I read that message
and I'm like, that's crazy.
Because I laugh, that means that I'm saying, "Yeah, yeah, that
would be funny." Right? That would be great. Actually, it wouldn't
even be funny. It would be great if that happened. Right? If
you laugh at something [__] up, that means you support
it. Under Willie Max shows
>> If you laugh, you support.
That [__] dude.
There are too many funny racists in the world for this to be
the standard, guys. I'm sorry. As long as Nick Fentes exists,
this can't be the standard. I'm sorry. That guy is funny. I'm
probably going to laugh at some. I cannot be said to support
him, okay? Just because I laugh. That's nuts, >> dude.
Come on now. Really? Look, the chat's insane obviously, right?
What are you supposed to do? If somebody says something that
you don't agree with, are you supposed to sit there and have
like a stern discussion with them? If somebody in chat says something,
right? Am I supposed to sit there and stop the flow of the whole
stream and just be like, "Hey, you said order taken." No, you
that's not what I'm saying at all. I'm going to stop the stream
right now and reprimand you. This is not
an order to go after Willie Max show. How dare you? You're supposed
to go into this
so you're he's mocking the idea that he would denounce going
after Willie M show? Does that mean that he's actually telling
us to go after the Willie Mac
>> the Willy M show Willy M show. >> Laugh and say,
"No, that's not what we're doing here." And that's what Queman
did. >> And look, maybe you can sit there and think in
your own minds that Queman is making a dog whistle. I think that
that's crazy. But sure that if that's what you really want to
[__] if that's how you honestly perceive this clip,
whatever, dude. But you're making a video saying not what you
think is going on here, not what you speculate or what could
be happening. You're saying this is fact, which is that he did
actually. But you know what? I don't even like giving that away.
I
Off topic in his band sucks. Um I don't even like giving that
away. Okay, that idea when you go, "Okay, guys, listen. He claimed
it as fact." If he had just gone, I suspect this is happening.
That would have been just like 99% as right. That would have
been 99% as it's it's not quite 100%. But you can't just go,
"Well, I'm pretty sure this guy's trying to dox me. I'm pretty
sure one of his community members do me and still not give away
any information."
That's [__] crazy. >> Queman is dog whistling
support for your >> even for the dog whistling point. Sure,
sure. Sure. >> And that Queenman is dog whistling and saying,
you know, without saying,
>> we'll cover some of the Zena stuff a little bit later
tonight, guys. Right now, we're doing commentary Civil War content,
okay? We'll get to the Zena stuff later. We'll get to some of
the the kick scavenger hunt stuff later. We're on to commentary
Civil War right >> You know, focus up. >> The real
honest part of what he wants to happen, he's kind of implying
to his audience, this is what's allowed now. Destiny said this,
we can do this now. That's Willie Max's argument. And if you
think that's a strong [__] argument,
>> I'll play it back just so that we get that clear. Okay,
look. I'm sorry. I'm going to play the clip again.
>> Tell me if you honestly believe that this is Queenin
Douglas.
>> I feel like we I feel like he has to do this for the
people in his audience, right? I'm probably going to skip through
his second viewing of this or I'll I'll speed it up a little
bit >> for doing whatever he [__] >> We'll
speed it up. you want to do to Destiny and his supporters? >> Destiny
actually uh called to my death said he he would he would kill
me. There was actually a moment in this video show Destiny having
to dox me as well since I'm not the only one. >> Oh, I
think this I think this cuts out the two points, right? Does
it? So Oh, no. No, it does. It does. Never mind. No, no, we're
good. >> Now, something interesting. I saw someone tweet
out >> absolutely true. Man who blanks a lot. Yes. Thank
god. Thank god Auggie has a spine. Thank god cuz holy [__]
It feels feels terrible for people to go like I'm pretty sure
these guys are just being lied about. I'm pretty sure these guys
are like totally being lied about. But um I don't like them.
I don't like them. So actually them getting doxed them getting
death threats. That's totally cool. Actually, that's actually
really awesome. When Destiny said he wanted these guys Yeah,
that that was based. That was based.
Okay. None of that. I don't like them. They're very interesting.
Little Steve.
Massa Mass Stevie said anything involving this bad empanada guy
or anyone that supports him is justifiable. Anything is justifiable.
>> No, we didn't cover it yet. We will get >> anyone
that supports him. >> Well, let's apply those standards.
Why are we saying this about bad panada? Well, it appears to
be because bada docks will max.
>> Would Destiny be saying that those who dox people, those
who violence or illusions to violence should be fair game and
all of their supporters and all of their supporters, okay? All
the personalities that back him up, all the chatters that back
him up, everything
and just everything against these people, anything is justifiable.
That seems to be the standard to me is that anything is justifiable
against Destiny and the people who support him. No, that's that's
what he's laying out for me here. Now, I have principles. I have
principles. I don't think it's no bad tactics, no bad targets.
That's not me. But Destiny is very clearly laying out that most
I can't tell if Auggie is just doing this to drive Nick Dioro
insane. We all know Nick Dioro gets all his takes from Auggie,
but this will crush him. No, I don't think Nick gets his takes
from Auggie. I think Nick gets his takes from himself. Auggie
would never have supported Jewish people for this
Okay, I I'm just joking. Auggie Auggie doesn't hate people at
all. Auggie didn't totally tweet swastika 5 minutes ago. Okay,
Auggie supports
except for Ethan Klein. Okay, except for Ethan Klein. Augie supports
people. Sorry, I I really can't I I really can't throw the first
stone on this one cuz I just straight up retweeted it. Okay,
that is a That's pretty funny. That's pretty funny. All right,
that's pretty funny. If you get it, >> it's it's a swastika
sword. It's a >> The standards that he believes in, those
are the standards he wishes to be enforced. Is if you're a doctor,
if you call for violence, anything is justifiable against order.
>> Okay, that's not what I'm saying, Max. I can explicitly
say otherwise actually, Max. But Destiny is clearly laying it
out for you. Destiny is clearly laying it out. He is saying this
type of behavior isn't okay. Anything is justifiable.
That's what I'm saying >> Okay,
that's the clip.
That's the [__] clip. And to me, I walk away from
that thinking, a Destiny's guilty of a lot of the same [__]
B and Bata is guilty of clearly. I mean, do you guys want to
know what Destiny's saying today as of right now in his chat?
>> I think I tweeted. >> Oh, what did he What did
he say? He did say this. Dude, I Augie is going to do all of
the content I had for later >> That's February of this
year. This is what this is saying right now in his
>> I am just hard. There's some dude in here who's like,
"Oh, JTO's reacting to somebody who's reacting who's like talking
about Destiny." Yeah, I was just going to cover this myself,
but it turns out most people think this is bad. I'm just hardcore
doxing anyone I can find information on now. So now their doxes
are getting posted. Okay, by the way, everybody who argues this,
I just want to point out there are a bunch of people who are
like, "Actually, this this form of doxing is totally okay, right?
Okay, just post your ID then. Go to your Twitter. Go to your
Twitter. Post your ID. If that's fine, if it's all fine, it's
all good. We should all have our identities revealed on the internet.
If you have a Twitter account, go and post your ID right now,
okay? Or your hardcore doxing anyone I can find information on
now.
So now their doces are getting posted. That's what Desty's saying
right now in his chat. And you know what else Desessie is saying?
Desi is saying that he doesn't give a about Willie Max's information
being spread because you can't be as open about it because now
you're also publicizing the docs, you know. But um I'm sorry
Willie. I don't know if this Willie or not. Oh, I guess he maybe
he sounds like a [__] but now I don't care. Now I
just [__] it up. If you're ducks, you're ducks. I'm
just gonna be I'm not gonna let that slow me down and outing
these
>> I'm not gonna let that slow me down and outing these
weirdos. Sorry, Willie. Sorry, Willie.
>> Dude, he hasn't even gotten to the part of the video
yet where where Willie starts sucking Destiny off for defending
him, right? Willy's like, "No, Destiny totally defended me, guys.
He totally defended me." Um, it kind of felt good when Destiny
defended me by spraying my docks, actually. Oh, cuz he was defending
me. And as he goes on to his stream, he's like, "Huh, I didn't
think about that
in born born of
whatsoever. I didn't think about that guy with fetal alcohol
syndrome even a little bit. I just went
I don't know why he had to point out that Willie is the product
of I don't know why he had to point out that Willie in fact has
fetal alcohol syndrome. Seems kind of up to me personally, but
he went up. He went off. He said those things. Destiny said those
things in real life. And Willie has Willy's totally rich now.
Willy's totally. He's got no His whole reason for differentiating
between him trying to to amplify Doc's information about other
people by replying to those tweets, right, was offset by, "Oh,
well, Destiny was trying to help me. Destiny just said he wasn't
trying to help you. He didn't give a about you. If you're getting
posted out there, if I'm signal
Wait, what? Hold on. Expand on that. Hold on. On the thing."
I kind of I kind of flubbed the joke at the beginning. When did
he say he had fet fetal alcohol syndrome? He is Irish. I All
Irish people have fetal alcohol syndrome. It's just what it it's
just like we literally can't tell them apart from the normal
population. They're Irish.
>> Boosting your information, which is exactly what he
did. We'll get into that later on in the video. Sorry, Willie.
Doesn't matter to Destiny. He doesn't give a about you. Guess
>> apologies to any Irish people in the audience. I'll
make it up to you at some point. You sit there and say in your
video that Destiny is like he did you a favor by standing up
against your docks. No, you [__] He's using your
[__] information
as a convenient tool against his enemies.
By the way, we all pointed this out that that was obviously what
was happening, right? We all pointed it out that Willie Dest
does not care about you. I pointed out with other evidence, right?
Like obviously if you want to point out that Destiny doesn't
care about these people getting doxed, you can just look at his
words, right?
When Hutch and Josiah get doxed in the thread. Hey Destiny, maybe
you should send it to them so they can see what people are doing.
Uh, send it to who? Josiah and Hutch and stuff. Oh me, they can
figure it out themselves. No, I don't really care that they're
docs. They they can just figure it out themselves. Those people
that when when I was a when I was, you know, shown to be a predator,
they walked away from me. They can figure their own doc stuff
out. Okay, those guys.
Good one. Very human reaction. Very normal person reaction. Very
warm-blooded reaction. Not at all a cold-blooded lizard person.
Not even a little bit. >> But he car. But guys, he cared
about Willie. He really cared about Willie, though. My god, this
guy's called him out earlier this year
for spreading some chick's news without her consent.
He's using you. He's using you and he's using your private information
that you obviously care about. He's using that [__]
conveniently for him. [__] figure it out.
Catch up. What are we doing here? This is why I say you're either
stupid or you're controlled opposition.
Because when Destiny does all the heinous that you claim to care
about and call out, you've got is silence.
Complete silence. He's using you. He's a sociopathic piece of
[__] I >> feel like Willie should have just
kept you and Quum out and just talk privately. You and Que didn't
really do anything and he obviously upset, but he took the worst
route. Wait, does that imply this person thinks I'm fine? I didn't
do any of this either. The [__] >> And apparently
I'm
Destiny broke your brain. That's Destiny's new cope, too. His
new propaganda talking point is that Destiny mind. >> I
don't get this proxy writing for Destiny when Willie literally
points out he has no issue criticizing the man on anything. He
has two videos in the guy FFS. Why isn't he why isn't he criticizing
the guy for doxing people? Apparently doxing's really bad. So
much so that he had to call me out for retweeting dickers. Okay,
but when when Destiny's just out here, Willie still posting in
Destiny's community, guys. Doxing's kind of weird.
Should I call it Destiny for doing it? No, guys. You you DG chatters
when you do is kind of weird. It's just a little weird. >> The
whole community if they call him out.
Yeah, good one. But apparently we don't take this tactic seriously
on people like Willie. Get it together, Willie. Figure it out.
You're being used. But let's continue.
>> So just to be clear, Destiny has now come out and said
that he did not give a [__] about Willie Mack. So
Willie Mack now has no justification for not going hard on Destiny
based on that clip, right? Like he actually has to call Destiny
out and say he's a total piece of [__] Willy M said,
"Well, Destiny was defending me. That's why he called out that,
right?" Nope. Will he was just using Willie getting docks as
a way to attack Bad Panada and say somebody should kill this
guy. That's all he wanted to do. And now Willie knows that, right?
So Willy's going to go and say, "Yeah, Desessie is a total piece
of [__] I I thought he tweeted my docs to I thought
he retweeted my docs to like defend me." Quote tweeted my docs
to defend me. What on earth would possess Destiny to do something
like that? I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
>> Let me back this point up now. >> But but Willie
now has no reason not to go and criticize Destiny directly,
Like that tweet should be crazy.
>> Sorry, the clip. The clip should be >> Standards.
Why are we saying this about bad empanada? Well, it appears to
be because bad empanada doxed Willie Mac's wife. So, would Destiny
be saying that those who dox people those who >> Actually,
before we continue, I do have a point of contention to criticize
Queen here because Queen, while I agree with
>> Yeah. When this originally when I originally got called
out on this, I was like, "Dude, I I I didn't even want to say
it, but it's like, how did Queen not get criticized at all?"
That'll be I hope AI goes over that, by the way. When When Willie
Mack was originally mad about me retweeting this clip, he didn't
say anything about Quean. Isn't that kind of weird that he just
didn't go after the guy at all? Right. Why did he not say anything
about Quman? He said I was like spreading his dogs apparently.
It's like, dude, what? But I I did say on the when we first addressed
the tweets from Willie like why how does he have no heat for
Queen at all? Like Queen is technically the person I don't think
Queen did this intentionally because I know his private thoughts
on this, right? Like on this kind of thing. So I know for a fact
that he wouldn't do this intentionally, but other people not
not privy to his private thoughts. Sure, they don't they don't
know this. I would just say you look at the past behavior. You
look at how he acted after this happened, right? You can you
can easily reach your conclusion just from that. So yeah, I I
just couldn't believe he didn't go after him in the first place,
but now he is. Okay, >> this argument and while I understand
and soberly I understand what he's saying up majorly here by
letting the clip play out. Okay, and I honestly believe that
this is a mistake. I don't see any reason why he's playing this
on purpose. I think he's just opening up links on Twitter and
he's just talking and [__] happening on screen, but
he's not really paying attention to it. But let's be honest here,
okay? This was a major up on his end by allowing this video to
play and it's playing muted. It's not like he's watching the
video to sort of Dude, look at his face. He's staring longingly
into his own eyes. Full screen camera on the second monitor.
He's just staring at himself. Okay, that's all he does when he's
when he's monologuing at all. >> Expose Willie, right?
He just opened up a link
and he's talking over the link and it's autoplaying.
I mean, let's be fair here. You know, he should not have let
this video play out. I think personally it's a mistake, but if
Willie if Willy's point of contention here was, "Hey, you mind
not letting my docs play while you're making this point?" He
would have won. >> Yeah. Literally literally everybody
would have been like, "Ah, it's kind of [__] up."
Qu would have been like, "My bad." He instantly would have won
if that was all he said. If all Willie said was, "Hey, stop playing
my docks while talking about this shit." That's it. That's all
he had to say. But that's not the argument that he's saying.
He's making additional crazy hypocritical arguments. But yeah,
if that's all he said was, "Hey Queen, you're a prick for playing
this. What the is wrong with you?" He wins because he's >> he
did also make that argument. He did not at the time, >> He
did not. So the the argument that Willie Mack show was making
when Auggie criticized him was, I guess we can just dox people
now because JTO retweeted a thing with my dogs. He was only criticizing
me. He never even went after Queman, right? And so why would
Auggie engage with the criticism of Quean when that wasn't what
Willie Mack was saying at all, right? So,
uh, Willie Matt's video is watching a stream where Auggie is
criticizing Willy Matt for saying doxing's on the table now.
I guess everybody just doxes now because apparently I retweeted
like this clip, something that something that quote tweeted this
clip where you couldn't see any of the docs information. So,
none of that was on my timeline. And apparently that made it
okay. Everybody's doxing everybody, guys.
No, obviously that's not the case. No, you're obviously making
arguments. And that's what Auggie pointed out. And then Willy's
like, "Well, he didn't even play the whole Quebec clip."
You didn't mention the Queen clip. You weren't complaining about
the Queen clip to
>> But that's not the argument that he made. Well, it is
one of the arguments he made. He, to be clear, he is upset that
Queen let the video play out, but he's not just saying something
like
>> No, Auggie. Augie,
his criticisms of you, I hope he realizes this, Auggie. The criticisms
of you are made based on you calling him out for being a on his
criticisms of me or his his comments on me, not on Queen. He
didn't comment on Queen cuz he is scared of Queenman. >> There
he's actually much more
about what's going on here, right? So yeah, and people in chatter
are saying might be time to leave again, Auggie. I just got destroyed.
>> I think Quimman is more than happy to use destiny tactics
because someone is ideologically against him. He's not someone
to stand with. Based on what? Based on what? Based on what? Based
on what? Based on what? Based on what? Based on what?
Do people just say things? You don't have to have any You don't
have to have any basis for the things you say. You could just
say, you don't actually need to You don't need to source anything.
You just make [__] up. It's fine. Do you really think
this is convincing anybody outside of your community? People
think this is unhinged.
Uh, I think it was a mistake. I don't think Queman did this intentionally.
I think Queman's upset that he did this. He He doesn't like that
he that he let this play, but it wasn't an intentional thing.
He accidentally did it. It's why he rectified it as much as he
could. What What's the unhinged thing here? What's the unhinged
thing that I did, by the way? What's the Why am I getting blamed?
I'm getting thrown in the in the pile with all of these people.
By the way, what what did my community do? My community post
cat gifts. And then Destiny goes over an album of it and goes,
"There, I just proved that this guy dots his people." And then
the failing again. This is perfect.
Don't stop people.
[__] off, dude. >> I just got destroyed, right?
That's the argument. Leave.
Okay. Sure.
Sure, dude. Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so stupid. Hex Marion with the five says, "No,
I think Queen is more than happy to use Destiny tactics because
someone is ideologically against him. He's not someone to stand
with." Okay. Well, you got to pro you got to demonstrate to me
where he's using these destiny tactics. You can't just say I'm
so sick and tired of people just saying stop saying show me.
Show me. Don't Don't tell me. Show
>> Sorry. This is a Destiny POV. He's about to He's about
to show that all these communities are connected to >> this
is about to get >> This is the proof, guys. This is the
proof. Hold on. >> Breaking clip. Destiny's finally found
the proof. >> I don't care. >> We're about to prove
it. watching my stream now in just Discord cuz I'm literally
the most entertaining thing they have to talk about. >> Oh
my god. Oh no.
>> Seven. This is basically now. >> Absolutely disgusting.
So many cat gifts. By the way, >> I don't know how there's
nothing going on also in any of these people's lives. Also, like
I'm doing this now. I have like
dozens of imager albums that people send me.
I have dozens of imager albums that people sent me of of of logs
from this Discord. Good one. Good one. >> I'm so [__]
sick and tired of people telling me because that's all that's
happened this year is people just keep telling me about these
people without showing me. You show me what you're talking about.
Demonstrate it. Have an example. If you're just going to say
I'm not trying to like go off on the donator
>> "Oh, sorry. Those cat gifts. That is an edited clip."
Um, there are instances where he's gone over a bunch of catg
posts, but that's an edited clip. It's not literally all cat
gifts all the time. There are just people talking about him.
That's That's the facts. Uh, Space Ghost, thank you very much
for the gifted sub, guys. I've not shilled yet. I'm going to
shield right now. We have $40. We need five. Sorry, four subs
to go two more hours on the stream. Okay, let's get those four
subs in, guys. Show your support. Get those four subs in. Two
more hours on the stream. We've got so much more content. Okay,
we got so much more. I need to get to all of it. Four more subs,
two more hours. Make it happen. Okay, there's also the TTS messages.
There's also the Patreon if you want to show support. I really
appreciate every bit of support I get from my community. Love
you guys. Thank you very much. Let's continue on with the content.
>> Sorry, bro. I'm just I'm using your argument to just
say, "Show me and don't just show me him being a show me malicious
cuz I don't care if he's an assh. I literally do not give a if
he or Jucker
to people including including my friends. I don't They're really
mean. They're really mean though. They're really mean." I might
sit there and say, "Oh, it's kind of up that you go after some
of my friends. I don't like seeing that." You know,
>> hey, soapbox society with the five gifted. Let's go.
Let's go. That's two more hours on the stream right there. You
love to see it. You love to see it. My botrix just logged itself
out. But thank you very much. I'll reset the meters and we'll
continue on with the content. not a reason for why I'm going
to disassociate with somebody just because they're
Show me that they're doing
boom. >> Are they doxers?
What are they doing? Show me show me the
>> Has Is this man unaware that there are dozens of imager
albums of logs of chatter saying things? X to thank you for the
five gifted. I really appreciate it, buddy. Guys, there's dozens
of albums. There's thousands of images of logs of chatter saying
mean things about Destiny. Doesn't that mean he gets to dox people?
I thought that meant he gets to dox people. Is that not what
it means?
[__] This is so simple. But yeah, just to be clear
here as we're watching this Queenman clip,
let me make it abundantly clear up by letting this clip play
out. But I'll tell you this. You know what he did when he found
out that Willie Mack had a problem with
>> All right. All right, I reset I reset all the meters
real quick just so you guys are updated. I reset the meters.
We'll reset that. We should be back to Yes. So, we're we're three
subs away from another hour on the stream if you guys wanted
to get those in. But don't worry about it right now. Appreciate
everything, guys. >> His editor at least removed the section.
JTO removed the quote tweet. >> I didn't even remove I
just retweeted Dickers. Dickers was like, "Oh, I guess Willie
Matt doesn't like this. I'll untweet it." But then we all criticized
him, right? I didn't even go to remove it. I wasn't even aware.
People were like, "Oh, it was so nice if Jay-Z talk to remove
that. He knows how bad it was." I don't know. I I probably would
have eventually, but I didn't go to do anything about this. I
was like, "Oh, I guess I guess this all happened. It was on my
timeline and then off my timeline with no intervention from me."
Like, if I if I saw it was upsetting him, I probably would have
removed it. But I knew that he was replying to like to DJers
posting what they think is my docs. I knew that. >> Uh
Dickers removed his tweet. Everyone, >> by the way, I don't
think I watched the full clip. I don't think I had any idea that
Willy's docs was in that clip. Right. I I think I might have
known that it was a Queenman clip, but I don't I'm pretty confident
I had no idea that the Willie stuff was in there at all >> that
propagated this. To be clear, I don't know if Quan did anything
about it, right? And I haven't seen Queman's response for why
he let this video play out. I was trying to watch Queman's response
to this whole video yesterday. Uh but his stream got copyrighted,
so I couldn't find out. I I wanted to hear Quimman's response
to this. >> Oh, he probably watches the monologue. I don't
know what uh response is to play the monologue
so doc hungry and so vicious. >> As soon as they found
out that Willie was deeply upset
by this Queenman clip,
Jtock deleted his tweet. Dickers deleted his tweet and even the
Clipper the throwaway account on Twitter. Even that guy removed
his tweet and re-uploaded it censored. So, everyone that is guilty
here took responsibility as soon as they were it was made aware
to them that Willie was upset and I'm supposed to look at these
people as malicious
>> Got it. Let's keep going. Would Destiny be saying that
those who dox people, those who make calls to violence or illusions
to violence should be fair game? And all of their supporters,
all the personalities that back him up, all the chatters that
back him up. >> This is essentially a Destiny snark community.
This guy's narrative for the past 6 months is that I'm covering
for Destiny despite me making two of the most in-depth videos
criticizing him. Their evidence behind this is I said Destiny
is better at covering the news than Hassan and Vosch, which is
somebody who has made videos on all three of these people. I
think that's objectively true, but I digress. >> I feel
like their evidence goes a little bit deeper than just >> it
was uh yeah, there were there were other pieces of evidence,
but the comment on that was um him saying him starting it off
with I really respect the way Destiny handles political disagreements.
I respect
verbatim I respect Destiny because he will meet his opponents
like in in conversation. He will go and talk to people directly,
right? I respect Essie because he will talk directly to people.
>> Just Oh, he said is what Willie says.
Well, totally dodging any conversation with anybody who has criticisms
of him. >> Something nice about Destiny in the video. And
I think it's pretty clear honestly that Willie Max >> very
sad
>> clearly does not hate Destiny. I mean, look at Willie
Max's interactions with Destiny post this drama. When the drama
happened in January,
uh, I went nuclear on Destiny. Even Dioro went nuclear on Destiny.
Everyone went nuclear on Destiny because that was the right thing
to do. Willie Max, on the other hand, you know, he didn't sell
all of his stock in Destiny. Let me just put it that way. That's
not to say that he uh, you know, didn't call Destiny out and
didn't make videos. This is the I'll just point out this is like
the only evidence that Willie has any literacy at all that Willie
is capable of critical thought is that he tiptoed his his his
criticism a little bit. Right? He slowplayed it. He tiptoed a
little bit. Right? That's the only evidence I have that Willie
is really sensient is he understands that his audience overlaps
significantly with Destiny's and he's not willing to risk that
right off the bat. He's not willing to just immediately risk
that for other people
>> covering Destiny.
But let's just be clear here, okay? Destiny still follows Willie
Max show on Twitter.
Obviously, whatever footage Willie Max show or whatever video
Willie Max show put up against Destiny
probably didn't bother Destiny that much in the grand scheme
of things. And I'm not sitting here saying that Willie Max show
has to go nuclear on Destiny. I'm not saying that Willie Max
show has to go live and call Destiny a
so that he can appease me or satisfy me so that I can be like,
"Okay, Willie, you've called out Destiny enough. You've gone
nuclear enough. I accept this." That's not what I'm saying. But
I think it's abundantly clear to anybody with eyeballs
that Willie Max show does not hate Destiny. >> Uh what
was it that what was it that Willie put in there? Right. The
one thing that looked kind of nice for Destiny was like Willie
sort of set the table a little bit, right? Am I misremembering?
Or after that first video, was he not like, "Well, Destiny kind
of implied to me that he's got some stuff that'll come out that'll
really change everybody's opinion on this, right?" And he just
puts that out there. Doesn't ask what it is. He just puts that
out there, right? I think there are little things like that that
it's like, "Yeah, you're not totally you're you're saying this
guy did bad stuff, but like it's not totally." And I I think
I tried to like let that go at the time, but when you look back,
given like where this has progressed to now, I don't know. It's
hard to It's hard to explain it. It really is. It's difficult.
>> I think that's pretty clear. He made a video talking
about what Destiny did was wrong. Oh, wow. Damning. He made a
video where he's like, "Hey guys, so recently Destiny did this,
blah, blah, blah. We're going to go through it." Sure, that's
fine. I think it's pretty clear Willie Max show, you know, is
not like a Destiny hater of any sort. And that's fine. That's
fine. He can just say that, right? You know, for all the that
Droop Lou gets, right? If you ask Droop what he thinks about
Destiny, he's going to probably tell you that he likes Destiny.
He's probably going to tell you that he doesn't give a [__]
right? You know, I think Willie Max show probably wants to see
good in Destiny. That's just me speculating, though. This might
be Look, I'll be fully honest here. Okay, this might be Drew
hates Destiny. Okay, well I I don't know much about him. I'm
just I'm just saying if you if you ask some Destiny orbiter in
his scene right now, they're going to tell you I like Destiny.
I don't give a Right. That's what they're going to say. And just
to be clear, I don't know what I don't know what Willie Max's
opinion is on Destiny. But I'll tell you this, I don't I wouldn't
be surprised if Willie ran those videos past Destiny before he
uploaded. Um, I don't think you would have done that cuz obviously
if those logs ever like then you know I is Willie dumb enough
to do that cuz then as soon as logs come out of that like Destiny
just has you by the balls for the rest of your life, right? If
you get his approval on any of this [__] I just maybe
maybe he's that dumb. Maybe he's that dumb.
I I don't know. I don't think that would be I don't think that's
something that happened. It's it's something you can ponder.
I don't think >> that he hates Destiny. >> Orbiter
who's left besides Connor? Um, Aerodite, Dan, Connor,
Tom Foolery, food shops. These would be like the five name off
the top of my head. >> I don't think that he hates Destiny.
And that's evidenced by the fact that when he's sitting here
on Twitter about how JTO and Quean are spreading his docks, but
then Destiny's the one doing it. >> Oh, Darius. Yep, Darius.
And then he's telling you
>> I don't care that Destiny spread my docs because uh
well
um you know my doc was already seen by everyone. My doc was already
seen by everyone. Okay, at this point it doesn't matter and Destiny
was supporting me.
Mr. Mutin is back in the fold. Um oh maybe. But I don't think
Mr. Is Mr. Mutin hanging out with Destiny? Maybe he is. I have
no idea.
I I maybe.
So, I don't really >> That's a super weird time to come
back. >> Really care that Destiny did it, right? >> Just
saying. >> Okay. So, let's establish the timeline there,
right? Once Destiny quote tweeted your docs and blasted it out
to 300,000 people, which happened by the way, you don't mind
that because at this point, everyone who was going to see your
docs has already seen it. But then when Queean and Jtock are
covering Destiny's tweet, you're upset
because they're spreading your docs even though we're past the
point where you're fine with people seeing it. >> Do you
guys understand why this makes no
>> The timelines don't make any
clearly watched the video. He's like referring to things further
in the video. It's very funny. >> Once Destiny makes the
tweet, apparently it's fine. Apparently, it's fine. Once Destiny
makes the tweet, whatever. Everyone's seen my docs anyway, so
it doesn't matter. At least Destiny is supporting me. I like
that. But then when Queen and Jaw cover it negatively against
Destiny,
suddenly it's a problem specifically because they're signal boosting
the docs. That doesn't make any sense. He's lying. Willie Max
show is lying to you. And I'd love for him to call into this
program right now and explain the timeline discrepancy here.
>> Oh [__] >> Can somebody in chat explain
it? Everyone in chat who's telling me to quit because I suck
at my job. Please explain to me the timeline discrepancy right
now. Do it. >> None of these people will call in and talk
to any of us. >> What's going on there? Why is it so easy
to pay forest
>> to spread your docks to 300,000
people? >> Do you think Destiny if given the chance would
change the last 2 years?
Um, like what do you mean? If given the chance, would he have
deleted that video? Sure, he would have deleted that video out
of those DMs or something if given the chance. But not not out
of like concern for Pixie at all, right? It just would have been
out of concern for himself. It's like he's just totally self-interested,
totally self motivated.
Well, self-involved, self-absorbed, whatever the whatever the
case is. He just doesn't care about other people. So, he wouldn't
delete it to help other people. He'd delete it to help himself.
>> But if J and Queen do it, they're bad because they're
spreading your docks. I mean, he's lying to you, obviously. I'm
looking at the chat. I'm waiting. And this is why, okay, here's
another point, right? This is why I called Willie Mack controlled
opposition. You know, I was watching Tommy C earlier today, right?
And Tommy C is just like, "Well, Aie, you got to prove that Willie
Max controlled opposition. If you're going to say that and demand
proof that Queen Dox's people or Yeah. demand proof that Queen
Doxes people, well, you've got to prove that Willie Max has controlled
opposition."
My argument is in the original stream. Anyone watching my ritual
stream understands why I was saying that Willie Max show might
be controlled opposition because he's fine with Destiny doing
something against him, but he's not okay with other people doing
the same thing, other people that happen to piss him off. Queen
and Jtock, he's fine with >> Augie's played the clip. The
only the only reason Willie gave for why that was okay was because
Destiny was defending him. Now Destiny's come out and said, "No,
I wasn't trying to defend him." Oh, sorry if I [__]
up, Willie. Sorry them doing it. Or sorry, sorry. He's fine with
Destiny doing it, but he's not fine with them doing it. That's
why I say he's controlled opposition because Destiny can do no
wrong. Destiny gets no criticism for him being a doxer, being
somebody that grabs people's doces, looks for people's doces,
publishes people's doces, tells people to go to QB farms to find
Anna's doces. Where's the criticism for that? But instead, Willy's
going to spend all this energy against people that have a issue
with him. And again, if Willie was mad at everybody equally,
if Willie was mad at Queman, if Will was mad at JCO, and if Willie
was mad at Destiny for all doing the same thing, which they all
did, by the way, they all did the same thing, which was engage
with the video that had your docs in it, then Willie wins. If
he was mad at people for the same, he's consistent. He's being
consistent here, but he's not being consistent here. >> And
that's why it's a very simple
>> How dare you, J? How dare you leave me out of the DG
com fountain orbit?
Uh, thanks for the three bucks, man. >> I don't mean like
Destiny is appointing Willie as some sort of like, "All right,
Willie, you're hired onto my team. You're going to be the guy
that says all the things that look like it's against me, but
in reality, it's controlled or whatever, right?" I'm not saying
that. I'm saying Destiny is a guy that Willie likes, and Willie
is willing to be infinitely more charitable to him than he is
other people that he covers. I think that's pretty [__]
clear. Anyone disagree? When I say control opposition, I'm not
talking about that he's in the IDF or he has some IDF wife or
that he's in a cabal of Destiny's moderators or something like
that. I'm not saying that. I'm saying that he likes Destiny and
he's willing to give Destiny a pass even when Destiny's doing
something up to him directly. That thing being Destiny signal
boosting Willy's dots.
>> Willy's going to sit there and say, "Oh, well, he was
supporting me, so I like what he did." Oh, really? Really, dude?
Come on, dude. Be reasonable here. That's like saying like if
I had Willy's address and I and I posted it and I was like, "Wow,
it's really that somebody just sent me Willie Max's address."
You know, this address right here on the screen. It's really
that somebody showed me this. Like, damn. You're telling me Willie
would sit there and just be like, "Well, he's calling out the
person who do my address and send it to him." No, that's if it
was Destiny. Yes.
>> Come on. So, I'm sorry. I barely gotten through this
video, but we have to >> Check him up. All the chat is
back. >> By the way, where are the people in chat disagree
with me? I noticed that everyone that had something to say is
gone. Where are the people telling me? Where are all the people
who sat there and said, "Oh, >> how is nobody How is there
nobody? Nobody will call in and make like any defense on any
of these things? There's literally nothing. How is there nobody?
How is there not one person who would hop on
to any of these streams? Did Queen find anybody? Augie can't
find anybody? Augie can't find Willie can't find a person, right?
None of these. Dude, how is that not just like how is the silence
not damning for these people that they have no defense for any
of the they're doing? The literally the thing that differentiated
Destiny's community from all these other communities was they're
the people who will hop on VC and argue about the right like
Discord are banned. There's a massive thing with Rally. It's
a massive thing with Pisco now. There's a massive thing with
Destiny. All these people Hey, get in the Discord right now if
you want to be a piece of [__] If you want to All
these people, they all the people who believe this, they're just
gone. They just all disappeared overnight. He fell off. Where
are they? What happens? All the people saying your destiny mind
you or something like that. Anyone?
Anyone here? Thoughts? Anyone? Well, I have one person chat.
Don't quit. But you're wrong here. Okay. Well, at least there's
people saying that I'm wrong with no argument attached. Got it.
>> Come on. This is essentially a destiny. >> Anyone
that could form a coherent argument left. I don't even think
that's necessarily true. I think there's just I don't think that's
even necessarily true. I think the problem is they can form a
coherent argument and they know that they lack the requisite
facts. the requisite pieces to build one. And so they'll shut
the [__] up, right? They will be a part of that community.
They will be a part of the throng. But when when people go, "Hey,
why are you here? Why are you why are you all doing this? Why
are you all like mobbing these people?" They'll go, "Uh, why
don't you ask that guy?" And they'll run away. >> Snark
community. This guy's narrative for the past 6 months is that
I'm covering for Destiny despite me making two of the most in-depth
videos criticizing him. They're evidence. >> More arguments.
More arguments. Uh, somebody in chat says, let me see here. I'm
loving the crash out. Keep it up. All I'm hearing is you're wrong.
You're crashing out. Good. You're really moving me with this
with this one. You're really changing my perspective here. And
look, unlike Willie, I'm willing to sit here and entertain an
argument that I am just totally off base here. If you tell me
something that if you tell me that I'm wrong, I'm not I'm not
just going to sit here and be like, "Fuck you." No. If you tell
me that I'm wrong, but then provide an argument, I'll sit there
and I'll read it. I'll be like, "Is that true? Let me think about
that for a second." Blah blah blah. I haven't heard anyone even
attempt to make an argument. It's never happened. Cowardly. >> This
is essentially a Destiny Snark community. This is >> Augie
should quit for not confronting Nick for implicitly supporting
Lily. Destiny Snark
for the past 6 months is that I'm covering sides from the other
side. Most in-depth videos criticizing him. Their evidence behind
this is I said Destiny is better at covering the news than Hassan
and Bosch, which is somebody who's made videos on all three of
these people. I think that's objectively true, but I digress.
But most importantly, it's that when these two do something stupid,
I make fun of them back. The truth is bada did not >> Dude,
I I've like tried not to hate on Nick too much cuz I think I
keep thinking he's going to like make the right call. Not out
of like even morals, but out of like rational self-interest.
You've built a career on being the guy who like sticks to principles,
who is about like internal critique of your group, right? So
that you guys don't allow crazy like John uh John Swan and all
these other people. I've been on stream. You've been on my stream
telling this story before about how you have to allow critique
within your community because otherwise you get really bad actors,
right? And so when Quimman has a critique of you, I know that
you by your own principles have to go and entertain that. And
you can't just allow other people around you to make unhinged
attacks. people who will defend you all the time. People who
are your friends who you are in group chats with. When they go
and attack Queen, when they go and lie about them, when they
go lie about me, lie about Queen, I suddenly know for a fact
that like you know about it. You're aware of it. You're in on
it. You totally you're totally behind it, right? You can try
to wash your hands of it, but you've been behind like these guys
going after us or trying to ignore us, whatever the like actual
relevant criticisms for months, and you can't escape this. There
is no escaping it. Take the L now. Stop the bleeding.
Just that out of rational self-interest. Take the L now and just
stop the bleeding. Don't let this blow up into something that
tanks you. Just talk to talk to Queen about his criticisms. I
I've heard them. They make a lot of sense. You could probably
explain them. You could you could just take the criticisms,
figure out your response, and then go, "Yeah, I up here." Or
say why Queen's wrong. By the way, that's totally an option.
Just so everybody knows, you could totally come in and go, "Here's
like where I disagree with those with those arguments. Here's
how I see it, right? That's all you got to do. That's all you
got to do. >> My docs, he maliciously spread it everywhere,
but my docs originated on a niche form by this guy's unhinged
>> Oh, okay.
Okay. So, Willie Max Show is going to confidently tell you guys
that his docs originated from a niche forum, Kiwi Farms. Or maybe
he's talking about spicy chat. I don't know. He's very vague
with his language. But what I was gonna say
originated from a Queenman viewer.
>> Where's the proof? No proof. But you know what guys?
Queman's anman's
mean to me. So [__] him, dude. That's the standard
that Willie M show is creating right now. Queen's an
got it. And by the way, people did look into who this person
was, right? Does somebody >> Wait, soapbox, he totally
can though. All you have to do is admit you did something bad.
You can admit you did something bad and here's why you did it
and here's how you'll fix it, right? Hey, I got really caught
up in it. I had a big audience behind me. That's my bad. I I
don't think I said anything that was a lie, but I probably didn't
apply my principles evenly, even though that's something I feel
like you should do. And yeah, I just got a little caught up.
Hey, it was like a mistake, but I I like Nobody's arguing that
Nick has totally violated his principles directly in most of
these cases, right? He hasn't. He's not like going out and saying
doxing's okay. He cut off Dan when when Dan was doing the doxing,
right? He hasn't come out and said doxing is okay. He hasn't
come out and said like, oh, like let's say the DMCA thing, DMCing
small creators to silence criticism. He hasn't come out and said
that's okay. He just attacks other people instead of actually
criticizing people who are on his side who are doing bad actions.
That's a little different. He's not violating his principles.
He's just not applying them
He can he can make that work. He can address that criticism and
come back from that. But if he keeps on doing this eventually,
now I would say his lack of ability to apply his principles evenly
is actually causing people around him, people who rely on him
for their reputations to go and just lie maliciously about people
that now Willie Mack is he will always be invoking your reputation
to say things unless you disavow him. Right? He's gone on things.
Him and Tommy C have both gone on stream and said, "Hey, we are
in a group chat with Nick. Nick doesn't trust you either. Nick
doesn't like you guys either." Right? They're invoking you. If
you're not going to step out and say, "No, these guys don't speak
for me. They're actually totally wrong and and give your opinion
on what they're saying that I mean
by Willy's by Willie standard seems like we uh we can infer some
things." No, I think your kick is just having a seizure here,
Frank. >> Know where the tweet is? People should be fine.
>> So, here's the thing, right? This guy on Kiwi Farms
that was responsible for doxing Billy Max show, he has two posts
on the Destiny thread and he's never once mentioned Queen.
There's no evidence now. Maybe he was a Queenman viewer. Again,
any proof of that? And even if he was a Queenman viewer, any
proof that Quimman is responsible for that? Are we now saying
that you're responsible for your audience? A position that everyone
in the commentary community has laughed at and ridiculed since
the beginning of time. Are we really sitting here saying time?
>> Dude, I just saw a really funny thing. Hold on. [__]
Burrito says, "Quean is a bad faith actor, former Destiny meat
rider and then went anti-destiny when I got clout off it. when
I can got clout when he when I can get clout off it. Dude, these
people are like actually subhuman. Like the the chatters in the
commentary community actually some of them subhuman incap like
I think I think somehow we found out that like Willie Max shows
audience
is they just actually all have like Down syndrome or something.
They like can't form they can't formulate thoughts correctly.
It's crazy. Queen is absolutely a former desi meat rider. I like
they're not even actually making a real criticism.
Your discord is sub. They're not. >> Are we really sitting
here? >> Vin, you probably just got timed out because you
were trying to you were trying to go after Destiny and get him
to throw you more albums. Okay. You want to criticize Destiny,
go to Destiny's chat. You want to you want to be unhinged about
Destiny, go to Destiny's >> Saying that you're now responsible
for your [__] audience. >> I'm not even saying
you said unhinged [__] I don't actually know what
she said. I just know that you constantly were typing about Destiny.
It's like, you can go over there, bro. Or we could put you in
the E- rapist Defense Squad channel. Remember guys,
remember when Quean laughed at a donation?
Remember when Queman laughed at a donation?
That's evidence that he's a doxer or that he supports the docs
or that he's responsible for the docs. Remember when he laughed
at a donation? Remember that? It's a stupid argument. This This
is literally the reason why I'm banned from Streamlabs. By the
way, Streamlabs has banned me for 5 years because I laughed at
a racist donation somebody sent in.
That's why I'm banned from Streamlabs.
>> We're using that logic now.
>> God damn it. >> Do you understand how stupid this
is? >> Oh, by the way, here's something. >> It's
not my fault. Racists are funny. >> It's not my fault.
It's not my fault. I should have called Max Hypocrisy cuz he
said in this video, Augie's just going to performatively hypocrisy
hunt. You guys want to know something? Willie Max show made a
video on Dark Viper AU. >> Dark Viper AU. >> Oh,
we I've seen this one. I think I might have this up. Augie's
just going to go through. Dude, I'm just going to run my stream
off Augie's. [__] it. >> That the commentary
community >> spent all this time getting these logs together,
getting all these clips together, and now Auggie's running all
of them anyway. >> Dox him. And Willie Max show thought
that that was stupid. >> You're prescribing a doxing allegation
to his community based on nothing. It's
>> It's crazy. >> You're prescribing a doxing allegation
>> It's crazy. So, Dark Viper is a [__] >> By
the way, one of the significant things they're building this
off of, again, for anybody who hasn't been here the whole time,
one of the significant things they're building this off of is
after Queen and I watched some Hutch content, Hutch's dogs got
posted in the KF thread. Okay, I don't really want to talk about
it, but it's like been brought up so many times. His his dogs
got posted. Okay.
Now, I believe what happened is probably somebody close to Destiny,
somebody adjacent to Destiny saw that, talked to Hutch and said,
"Hey, it's because of these people going after you. I told you
they were unhinged,
right?" Probably most likely leaving out the fact that Hutch
was actually doxed in that thread for the first time in September
2024 before Queen was like an vocal Destiny. Well, actually,
he was a vocal Destiny antif before that, but not over this stuff.
And before I I was still like a Destiny fan in September 20 well-ish
in September 2024,
right? So how in the world are they trying to spin this as like
oh well these guys got doxed because they uh they watch Hutch
is Hutch got doxed because he was getting watched by Queen and
Kiwi Farms talked about him. No, Hutch got docked because of
his proximity to Destiny and for no other reason. Queman's and
we're going to go over that later. We'll go over the Hutch combo.
Quimman's lack of willingness to say Hutch isn't a Destiny Orbiter
has nothing to do with Hutch getting doxed. If Quimman had said
that, people on Kiwi Farms would have gone, "Oh, I guess Queen
is sweeping now, right?" Why is Queenman going to throw himself
in the line of the bullet for Hutch when he doesn't even believe
that Hutch is an orbiter? Find out today. Apparently, Hutch is
starting a podcast with Noterite, Destiny's 50-50 business partner.
right now. I don't think anything bad I I totally disavow bad
things happening. Do not do anything to go after this person.
Do not do anything to go after this person or make them feel
any fear in real life. You want to say, "Hey, it's kind of weird
that you like give these takes. You want to you want to criticize
the things he says?" Criticize the things he says. There's no
reason to do anything in real life. It's insane. I hate when
people do this. Just talk [__] on the internet like
every other god-fearing
North American. Okay? Just talk [__] on the internet.
That's what the internet is for. So we can talk about each other.
So we can say things you wouldn't say to somebody's face, right?
Well, not for me, but I I assume for other people, right? You
can say unhinged.
It's like a fun thing. It's the internet. You just be unhinged.
It's crazy. But to try to bring that into somebody's real life
to me just seems it seems nuts. I don't know. Anyway, we continue
>> I just I think it's I'm going to have to do like a big
I'm going to have to collect the information on this and go and
like make a post or something cuz especially for you. I said
no, not for me. Uh, he said that everyone in commentary doxed
him, but you're justified for saying everyone in Queenman's community
is doxing you. If Willie Max has any information suggesting that
his docs originated from Queenman's community, please. Please,
I'm begging you. It's not please. We should stop saying please
here. Okay, Auggie needs an update on what the talking points
are. Okay, you are compelled to post that evidence and not protect
somebody who is doxing people. If you have evidence of this,
you are a scum for not posting it. It's not just like, "Oh, please
do post it so we can know about the allegation." No, you are
a complete piece of [__] for not posting that and
protecting a docer.
How about don't How about don't protect doctors? How about ban
doctors? Get doctors banned from other communities. How about
we just all go back to before we pretended Destiny had any point
here beyond being a totally unhinged
person motivated entirely by personal spite petty loser? How
about we go back to the time before we believe that he had anything
interesting to to contribute to the conversation and we go back
to when doxing was bad? How about that? How about we stop pretending
Destiny has anything relevant to say that he's a that he's a
good faith actor? That he's motivated by anything but spite and
we just go back to doxing bad. How about that? Why not? What
a [__] novel idea. >> Show it to me cuz he
didn't show in this video. He didn't show >> stupid. I
make fun of them back. The truth is bada did not originate my
docs. He maliciously spread it everywhere. But my docs originated
on a niche form by this guy's unhinged viewers. So when I see
this >> clip, it's obviously a dog whistle to [__]
with me. He literally gets a donation that says, "I understand
what we must do." Wink wink. >> Anything is justifiable
against Destiny and the people who support him. No. Is that not
the standard? That's that's what he's laying out for me here.
Now I have principles. I have principles. I don't think it's
no bad tactics, only bad targets. That's not me. >> As
he's literally showing my docs, >> but Destiny is very
clearly laying out that those are the standards that he believes
in. Those are the standards he he wishes to be enforced. is if
you're a doctor, if you call for violence, anything is justifiable
against you, you >> Order taken. >> Okay, that's
not what I'm saying, Max. Actually, I just explicitly said otherwise,
actually, Max, >> he's got a grin on his face. He knows
what he's doing.
>> What? What?
Are you kidding me? He's got a grin on his face. He knows what
he's doing. What? So, if you ever laugh at something somebody
said in your chat, you support that. Come on, man. How are you?
Come on. >> I know. We all know it's Max. We all know it's
Max. We'll watch the Queenman monologue after this if we need
to. >> People really expect you to watch this and believe
it? Are you kidding me? Seriously, dude. This is laughable. This
is Keel's dear. How is this not Keles? Well, there it is. There
it is.
There it is, guys. He laughed. Got him. >> Thing is justifiable
against supporters. >> Order taken. >> Okay, that's
not what I'm saying, Max. Actually, I just explicitly said otherwise.
Actually, Max, >> he's got a eating grin on his face. He
knows what he's doing. >> Dude, people say up in my chat
all the time that I don't support. If I laugh at it, does that
mean that I support that? Or am I just a human being with eyeballs
and I can see somebody do something? I laugh at
We all do. What? We all laugh at [__] Hello. Oh,
I don't. Yeah, shut up, dude. >> Isn't that just a ch thing
usually? Sorry, we're talking about the the playful disavowels.
No, I do the playful disavow, too. But I try to differentiate
between them, right? I try to say like, "No, no, no." Like, for
real, guys, like actually we're disavowing this. Like, like it's
not like a haha. I feel like you can tell my voice, but I try
to differentiate between them completely. Like I it's it's obvious
when I'm joking. It's obvious when I'm not >> Shut the
in my opinion. >> It was then gets retweeted by his friend
Jawalker who pushed the ex. >> And look, if Willie wants
to analyze that clip and be like, "This is suspicious."
Sure, maybe he can do that. Maybe Willie Max can look at this
clip and be like, "Huh, he smirked. He laughed. Maybe there's
something here. Maybe there's something to this."
But we are like way too [__] early to cast this guy
out as some sort of like malicious doc supporter. Like we are
way too early. No change. >> It's like a pattern of people
donating unhinged [__] so that the streamer can go
like totally disavow that. But it's like kind of funny, right?
There's like a line that everybody in who's in the community
can tell and participates, right? Like we all participate in
the same community. We all know where the line is. It's like
ha there's a little over the line but not really far over the
line. Like there are some things like if you tweeted something,
you know, involving kids or like any I go not tweeted. If you
donated something like that, I go, "Oh, that's gross. Don't do
that." Right? Like you can kill the vibe. But sometimes it's
like, "Oh, you go a little over the line with like a race joke
or something and it's like uh unfortunately that's funny." Right?
You donate with the Asian voice, you do a funny like Asian accent
in the dono. Unfortunately, I'm laugh at that. Okay? And I'm
going to go, "That's that's gross. Do not do that. I do not allow
that. Laughter is not meowing that." Okay. Uh, let's be clear
here. Willie is being dishonest and knows better. Yeah, he is.
He is. He is. The I know what I must do thing is such a common
meme. Yeah, it's the Trump. It's the like ma meme, right? I hear
you loud and clear, Mr. Trump. Is this not Is there not a comic?
Hear you, Mr. Mr. President. Yeah, this is like the the meme
or whatever here, right? I'll handle them, Mr. President. Like,
this is the this is the thing. These are horrible horrible people.
I'll handle them, Mr. President. Right. It's like you're you're
you're like criticizing somebody. And of course, there's a unhinged
schizophrenic somewhere who's like, "I get what you're saying
here. I know what you're doing. I know what you're I know what
you're saying here, man. I know what you're saying." In hell,
I'm going to look at a clip like this and be like, "He's done."
Come on, dude. At worst, this clip is like a minor red flag.
Something just to remember later if something else more incriminating
happens. At worst, that's what this clip is. >> He's got
a eating grin on his face. He knows what he's doing. This then
gets retweeted by his friend Jtock, who pushed the exact same
narratives about me. I'm obviously very unhappy about this. It's
affecting my real life, but instead of >> pushed the exact
same narrative about me. What? >> Ju pushed the exact same
narratives about me. I'm obvious >> I didn't Oh, the narrative
is that he is a Destiny sweeper. I think I gave him
I actually think I was I was wrong here. It seems like he is
like kind of a Destiny sweeper, but I totally just gave him the
there. I was like, "Yeah, I think you're too I think you're too
illiterate, too. I think you're too brain damaged to actually
like evaluate these things." And you know, I just gave him the
out. But yeah, he totally he totally seems to be like an SC sweeper
and malicious. >> Very unhappy about this, it's affecting
my real life. But instead of anyone actually acknowledging this,
they do what Bad Empanada did and try to hypocrisy hunt to justify
their actions.
>> Oh, they try to hypocrisy hunt to justify their actions.
Justify what? Now, is William Max saying that we're trying to
hypocrisy hunt to justify Queen covering the clip or you getting
doxed at all? No, he's saying he is saying that
we're we're trying to maliciously repost his docs by saying that
we're calling out Desty's hypocrisy. That's what he's saying
here, right? And like I guess I could see how Willie might think
that, right? Oh, it's really convenient that you guys are like
reposting this and I could see how he might think that. Um but
one like we've just totally disavowed these kinds of tactics.
We've had like long discussions about how these kinds of tactics
are unhinged. It's crazy, right? Man, there's there's like a
little bit more here. Oh, the hypocrisy hunting thing. Oh, but
also Willie tries to make the point later that he doesn't he's
not like amplifying doxing information about anybody else because
on a 100,000 view tweet, he added 5,000 views with his own tweet,
right? That's that's like the argument he makes. And it's like,
okay, by that argument, when we all respond to Destiny's thing,
we literally cannot overcome Destiny's reach. Destiny is the
person who's amplified this the most. So he he exposes his own
by saying or sorry he excuses his own actions by saying well
scale-wise I don't add anything here but he totally holds us
responsible even though scale-wise we had nothing to destiny
like doxing him. Destiny is spreading his docs. >> He's
very vague here. I mean I don't know. I'm just going to assume
he means like cleaning. But that's very strange language there.
>> Why aren't you mad at Destiny? He quote tweeted your
docs too. >> Why aren't you mad at Destiny himself? >> Destiny
is defending my already viral docs that's already in the hands
of all the people who hate me. We're acting like context and
scale don't matter.
What? What are you trolling? Okay, so if context and scale do
matter and Desi's already Look, my doctor's already out there,
dude. Like, what do you expect? Okay, well then why the [__]
you mad at Queen and Jay- Sock then? Their tweets are after
>> Yeah, sorry. Not I I didn't pre-watch this. I swear
to God. >> Destiny's tweet. What? And also, I am taking
context and scale into account. Specifically scale. You want
to talk about scale? Destiny tweet has 200,000 views. That's
scale. 200,000 people saw your docs because of Destiny. How many
people do you think Queman's tweets got that viral or went that
viral or Jtock? No. So, I actually am taking scale into account.
And when I take scale into account, Destiny you over way worse
than Queen and Jtock. But look, here's the thing, right? I'm
not going to get that with it. If Willie Max was mad at all of
them equally, that would make sense. I would get it. if he was
mad at Destiny for quote tweeting it in the first place and then
Queen and Jay for looking at the quote tweet again Willie wins
his critique stands against all of them because it's equal and
he's being
>> tweet
I just have passed for one thing
for another thing >> and sit there and act like they perpetuated
a doc against him because he doesn't like them cuz he they off
this video is good >> you're docs too >> why aren't
you mad at Destiny himself. >> Destiny is defending my
already viral docs that's already in the hands of all the people
who hate me. We're acting like context and scale don't matter.
It was actually kind of nice to see someone with a big audience
who I've criticized in the past stand up for me and say this
is wrong.
what the bro? >> Um, it's actually kind of like I kind
of don't mind when Destiny when Destiny tweets my docs when he
amplifies it. I kind of don't mind it cuz like he's defending
me. Oo,
he's defending me. I really like it when Daddy Destiny defends
me.
Okay. Well, actually, Destiny went out today on his stream and
said, "Yeah, I I'm not trying to defend you at all. I just want
to go after bada."
So, this this whole rationality he just gave for his whole reason
for not going after Destiny is gone. So, obviously, he's going
to go tweet out some Destiny, right? Like, what the dude, right?
Right. >> Actually, it was kind of nice what Destiny did.
Oh, really?
Got it. >> But look at this comment. Willie refuses to
acknowledge the obvious. But why why are you guys saying that
I I like defend Destiny? Why are you guys saying I help Destiny?
Why would you guys say that? It's so gross. It's so gross. >> It's
that Destiny is the biggest proponent in spreading his docs.
No, it was actually bad empanada who did that. Do you know how
time works? They hate Destiny so much they're ignoring the very
reality we live in. That's what I don't get at all. >> Listen
to that language. They hate Destiny so much. So Willy's using
Destiny's talking points here, which is that, oh, you're just
minded by Destiny, blah blah blah. And he's also like that's
such a cop out to that argument, too. Let me go back to that
original Reddit. Willie refuses to acknowledge the obvious that
Destiny is the biggest proponent in spreading his docs and and
Willy's his big response to this is like M actually bad at Banata
is the biggest proponent of the docs. Brilliant. But we're talking
about Destiny Queen and JC you [__] Don't m actually
your way out of this. You know what the person's saying out of
the people that are reacting this clip. You have an issue with
two people. No issue with the one person who's doing the most
amount of damage. Actually, bad empanada is the one that shared
it technically. Um, technically, come on, dude. At least try
to engage with what the person's saying. >> Proponent in
spreading his docks. No, it was actually bad empanata who did
that. Do you know how time >> Willie Max when he makes
his point, he's like, "Oh, got him. Come on, dude.
>> Like, unfortunately,
it's really hard to even follow this. You You have to pause so
much during this video. It is so poorly argued and put together
that you almost can't even argue with like the video effectively
because every 3 seconds you let play he says another
thing, right? Like it's so hard to react to. He made an unreactable
video. It's just argument after argument after argument. It is
so thickly laid on that it's difficult to even evaluate it >> They
hate Destiny so much they're ignoring the very reality we live
in. That's what I don't get at all. Is he perfectly fine with
his docs being spread around as long as the person who's spreading
it is condemning it? At this point, my docs is already spread.
The toothpaste is out of the bottle. What bothered me most in
this moment was the narrative that I deserve or that it's No
way. Hold on. Hold on. Hold hold on.
Is Anna Kasparian the new queen? Uh-oh.
Anna Kasparian answers why she won't debate Destiny. Anna, if
the truth is out there, why do you keep running from a debate
with Destiny at the Omni Liberal? I think it's because I read
his DMs about how he likes to walk around in public with a butt
plug a few days a week and I can't take him seriously after that.
Yeah, true. True. That's That's pretty true. Yeah, that's true.
That's kind of true. W Anna Wa Kasparian, she won.
Massive W. Ana Kasparian.
I'm going to go to my Twitter right now so I can find that tweet
and retweet it because Anna Kasparian won again. Let's go. Hold
on. That can't be that far back, right? Is it a day ago? Hold
on. Hold. Are you holding on?
I'll just retweet that right there.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's pretty funny. Yeah. That's That's
pretty funny.
at Grock, what does having a butt plug in your ass? This is a
DGR.
Actually, that's that's a what aboutism. Destiny can argue for
political beliefs even with his plugin. Okay. actually all that's
a that's a what about ism that doesn't actually critically engage
with Destiny's political beliefs. No matter how many gallons
of semen he swallows, he can still effectively argue political
Okay, read his response. Is his response uh uh let me predict
his response. You got by a hobo, right? Is that you? You let
yourself get out of your political beliefs. Why is Anna inventing
sexual fantasies that she has about me? I'm flattered. Really?
You literally What? Wait, did he not did he not say those things
when the honest truth is she's just too stupid to engage in adversarial
conversations about her new unhinged beliefs? Uh, no. I don't
think she made that up. Wait, I don't think she made that up
at all. What? Hold on. Okay, that's You know what?
>> Nobody said that. >> Is he denying the butt plug?
Is he denying that it was his wife's butt plug that he secretly
took and used when she was traveling?
Is he denying those details? That's kind of weird that he'd deny
those details that he streamed in it consistently. Uh oh, that
means he's embarrassed by it. Yeah, I don't know why he would
deny that. I thought he was I thought he was standing on business.
I thought he was plugged up on business. No, I hope I I It seems
like Anna's not going to respond. She could easily just respond.
Wait, are you are you saying you didn't you didn't message a
19-year-old while doing your job about the butt plug that you
were scared you would swallow? Wait, did that not happen? I could
have sworn that
What the? >> At this point, the the tooth was out of the
tube. I just had to accept that at at this point. Except when
Jason and >> oh 19 being charitable, I just don't want
people to go and come in and go why you said the 19 whose age
you didn't >> Cover it. But you know what? I was really
mad at the fact that they said that I deserve it. Nobody said
>> by the way. Yeah, nobody said that. >> Play the
clip of somebody saying that. It didn't happen. >> That's
a brutal comment. He would make so much money if he let DJers
donate for 5 seconds of buzz during streams. Oh, he Oh, he would.
They're so gross. But he would make so much money. Oh, that's
disgusting. Now I have to deal with Ah, anybody got a gun? I
This is the one moment. Okay, this is the one moment that being
Canadian has come back to bite me in the ass, okay? Because I
don't own a revolver with which I can blow my own brains out
after reading that comment. So, thank you, Top Bronson. You gave
me a reason to regret being Canadian.
[__] you very much. >> Some greater destiny
justice. If Queenman pulled up my docks and only said bad empanada
sucks for this, I wouldn't care. It's the dog whistle call to
action that's the problem. It's
Oh, okay. If Queen had pulled up my docs and said that it was
bad, I would be fine with that.
So his >> queen had gone bad is bad before his before his
comments, then this whole clip is fine. apparently >> original
point that Queman let the video autoplay which is actually a
fair point to make against Queman. That's actually a good point.
Willie is throwing that >> uh Destiny is coming to realize
that the thing that like works against him most as a serious
political actor is the fact that he had these insanely degenerate
DMs leak, right? That's what that's what actually works against
him as a serious political commentator. And people can go and
they can try to be progressive and all of this [__]
about [__] right? But it's like no, the weird diaper.
Yeah, the weird diaper puts people off, bro. I'm sorry. It really
do. It really do. Didn't he take pride in having nothing to hide?
Uh, well, he did before they found out what he was hiding. Now
he's being more honest. Okay, just I don't think that happened.
How much you want to bet that if somebody like quote tweets him
and shows him the DMs where he talks about this, he'll go, "Actually,
I said I just wore it like twice or something." Uh, I didn't
say I wore it for days.
Actually, you're misquing me. Aren't you like looking at re like
maliciously leaked DMs of me? Isn't that Isn't that like revenge?
Leave alone the fact that I actually leaked other people's DMs
of me. Leave alone that and that I threatened to do it multiple
times in the past. Um anyway, that argument in the trash can.
He's saying actually I'm fine with him playing it. But the issue
that I have is that he
made arguments justifying my docs. No, he [__] didn't.
So even like the legitimate complaint, I still hold that complaint
against Queman. I think Queman is an idiot for letting that video
play out, right? But Willie Maxwell is not making that argument.
In fact, he takes that argument and he dismisses it. He throws
it away. He actually tells you he doesn't mind Queman showing
you the docs. It's what he said that's the problem. But in reality,
what he said isn't the problem at all. So, this whole video is
pointless. I can't believe he really actually takes the good
argument that he has against Quean. >> Oh, why? Why? Why?
Stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. You all have to stop. You all have to
stop. You all have to [__] stop. Actually, this needs
to end. Jesus Christ.
Jesus [__] Christ, dude. What are you guys doing?
What are you guys doing? >> And just crumples it up and
tosses it
>> See, that's an example of a playful disavow. I actually
think it's hilarious to make fun of Destiny being a degenerate
freak. >> The garbage can. No, >> I don't actually
disavow that. I think it's hilarious when you do it. See, that's
a playful disavow right there. I'll come out and I'll laugh about
it after. >> Have a point against Queenman. That was the
point to make. But you actually said that that's a point to make.
Oh, okay. Wow. Holy [__]
>> So obvious. Yet I'm seeing respected commentator Auggie.
Call me a hypocrite. >> Okay, here we go. Now, he played
a little bit of me. Okay, let me go to the bathroom first. I've
been holding this minute now. Let me go to the bathroom first
and then we're going to get into my uh spanking that I took this
video.
punishment. All right, be right back. >> Hey yo, the
[__] this mother saying? What is this guy saying?
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh uhhuh.
Should be relegated to only debating other weird fetishists.
It's like there's a lot of different things going on there where
he's like not a serious person, right? Like one of them would
be fine. Maybe like Glenn Greenwald. Maybe Glenn Greenwald comes
back after his weird
his weird video, right? Maybe.
But like, dude, having like the the weird tweets about like kids
and
not just that, the weird tweets kids, having the firefighter
tweet, having like these weird DMs, >> leaking DMs about
the people who are already victims of you non-conensually sharing
their right, like there's just so many things rolled together
that at this point, how do you take him >> He's not a serious
person to say >> would be a banger drama streamer, though.
He could be really effective in that. If he just admits that
he's a total degenerate, that he has no principles, he could
probably run the table. He'd probably take back some of the Nicholas
Yoro audience if he wanted to, but instead he wants to larvate,
right? And is just exposed now as a complete LAR. >> In
this moment was the narrative that I deserve it or that it's
part of some greater destiny justice. If Queenman pulled up my
docks and only said bad empanada sucks for this, I wouldn't care.
It's the dog whistle call to action. That's the >> I can't
do an Asian accent for you, Jay's talk. But Destiny said being
plugged up for stream feels riri.
>> problem. It's so obvious. Yet I'm seeing respected commentator
Auggie call me a hypocrite because I said doxing is >> This
is from a month ago. >> Will you delete this? It's just
doxing and a to do to someone whose worst crime is being annoying
on the internet. So you have that situation there. So there he
is twice replying to Jtock's docs, but then he got upset about
his docs being shared. >> Yeah, holy. >> Oh, interesting
point here. Willie is convinced that Queen's disabels are tongue-in-cheek
dog whistle or tongue and cheek dog whistles, but Desty's constant
stream of I love little kids jokes are obvious jokes. Kind of
interesting how how just your opinions on people totally inform.
There's no there's no rational basis to either of those. You'd
think if you if you want to say one of them's dog whistling,
you'd probably say both, right? >> It's as if context matters.
It's as if me calling out a tweet that already has 100,000 views
doesn't add. >> I will say there's probably more evidence
of Destiny having conversations with minors than there is of
Queen and doxing people. I'm just going to say what is clearly
true, right? If that's your bar for evidence, just hey, it kind
of seems suspicious here. There's definitely more evidence of
Destiny possibly having conversations with minors than for Queen,
right? Well, wait. Possibly. Wait, hold on. No, Destiny's just
admitted that he has had conversations where minor are sending
him like bikini pictures, right? Oh, no. Sorry, I forgot the
older law the the naked ape stuff. Oh, [__] Wait,
there's just way more evidence of that. Never >> Any negative
effect? >> Wait, what? He's making a view argument here.
Wait, what
>> matter? It's as if me calling out a tweet that already
has 100,000 views. >> It's a tweet that has 100,000 views.
So, he's allowed to comment under people's doxes if he perceives
that they
>> weird conversation with what are we say? I'm sorry,
dude. This is just stupid. What are we [__] saying
here?
Upset about [__] his docs being >> Yeah. Holy
[__] It's as if context matters. It's as if me calling
out a tweet that already has 100,000 views doesn't add any negative
effect. He pearl clutches and gives this. >> So, if you're
adding less than 5% of the views to something, it's fine. You
can just engage in that. leave alone. Okay, let's let's not pick
that apart how that is. Okay, if you just take his logic as it
is, then he can't criticize me or Queenman or Dickers or whoever,
right? if you just take the logic as it is. But if you actually
go 1% further, okay, one tiny little bit further and go, well,
if everybody thinks that, then technically everyone who decentralized
who in a decentralized way retweets some, you know, revenge,
let's say, let's use a example DJs could be aware of. Okay, let's
say you retweeted uh the videos that leaked of Destiny, Destiny
by himself or Destiny sucking dead or whatever the [__]
right? Let's say you retweeted that. Is that fine if you only
added like 2% of the views to that? Is that fine? Seems like
it would still be wrong. Seems like that's not a good argument
at all. Seems like you'd have to be a complete [__]
to make that argument in the first place. Oh well, I only I only
did 2% of the stabbing of Caesar, so I shouldn't be held accountable.
Says a Roman senator circa 2 BC or I think the year Caesar dies
is when they go, right? Is when they switch or is it is it like
40 BC? I can't remember. [__] it.
>> I showed you two times. Here he is doing a third time
just a few days ago before I even did this stream and I actually
had to like tell him. I was like, "Dude, delete this," right?
>> But on the same stream, Augie shows the uncensored link
of JTO. >> Damn. Got him. You got me, by the way. Sure.
Okay. I I tried to censor most of the JC stuff, right? I missed
this one clearly. Okay. So, he got me here. But do you know who's
tweeting out this [__] link?
Do you know who's tweeting out this link? >> Somebody who
Auggie has total blindness when criticizing. Okay. Sorry, not
Auggie. Willie. Willie can't see them. In terms of criticism,
he can't see the person who tweeted this link. He can't see it.
44 BC. I knew. >> Does Willie have anything to say about
Destiny tweeting out this link? >> Yeah. It's
>> after death, right? >> We're going to try to do
like a gotcha here and be like, "Well, you showed the link there,
therefore you got him." >> Docs. You also replied under
Jox's docs on Twitter.
>> Willie, I replied under Jox's docs that you posted
and then you deleted it. You going to talk about that?
that this is your tweet that you deleted because I called you
out. Hello. And also that's not my argument. My argument isn't
that oh well if you replied with >> his argument is uh
it would be to go and like throw a hissy fit over this, right?
That that's like Auggie's argument in this. I I'll remind you
that at this point when Auggie did this stream originally,
he was criticizing Willie for saying I amplified his docks. He
was not criticizing Queman, right? Queen was not brought up by
Willie. >> But like therefore you're whatever, right? No,
I'm calling you Alex for >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no. Hold on. To be clear, the uncensored thing,
this one is Destiny tweeting this. The next one where where Willie
quote tweets and goes, "A shucks, it seems like everybody docks
us now. A shucks, it seems like everyone's a doxer now." When
he does that, that is Willie quote tweeting Destiny from that
same tweet. And Auggie did show it uncensored and I sent him
a message being justifiably angry. And I raped with this >> flight
under Jay- Sock's docs that you
and then you deleted it. You gonna talk about that?
That this is your tweet that you deleted because I called you
out. Hello. And by the way, if this isn't a bad thing to do,
then why did he delete it? Like Willie Willie can't apply any
standards like
uh what do you call it? Any standards equally, right? He just
has he just has no standards. bail docs. By the way, I think
when when Auggie showed that one uncensored link, I was like,
"Hey, Destiny's doxing like a way less fat guy this time. You
should go pull that up on your stream." Actually, I'm giving
you permission.
Just Just please stop letting people use that other picture that
looks nothing like me, okay? That isn't me, looks nothing like
me. Please just pull up the other guy. Pull up the other guy
for the love of God. >> And also, that's not my argument.
My argument isn't that, oh, well, if you reply to a fox, like
therefore you'reing them or whatever, right? No, I'm calling
you out for being a hypocrite. You're replying to people's docses,
but then getting mad that they're quote tweeting screenshots
of your docs.
I'm calling you out. I'm putting I'm I'm I'm holding you to your
own standard. People People around revoked and they don't realize
that the aura loss from being considered like a fat blob is horrible.
Okay, it's horrible. As soon as I'm on as soon as I'm on YouTube
for like a established period of time, I'm facecaming immediately.
Okay. Not before that, but as soon as I'm on there for any established
amount of time, I'm I'm It's going to happen instantly. >> The
That wasn't my point. >> So, what are we talking about?
Are we going to call Auggie a doxer? No, because they don't actually
care about this. He's just being performative to >> Willie,
are you lost? I'm calling you out. I'm I'm I'm specifically pointing
out that you're the hypocrite here. What? This is not my standard.
This is your standard. And I'm >> Yes, Willie. Willie doesn't
understand that the complaint isn't about you spreading docks.
It's saying if you're applying the standard then you also spread
docks. So you obviously don't apply the standard. You're a complete
[__] Are you a Maple? Yeah, I am a Maple Leaf fan.
Huge Maple Leaf fan. >> Holding you to your own standard.
>> No, that didn't happen. >> That didn't happen.
That never happened. >> What's happening to me? Auggie
X confused throughout this entire segment. >> Literally
days after he threw a hissy fit. Yeah. I mean, it just doesn't
really make any sense to me. It's like, what the are we talking
about here? I mean, what are what argument are we making here?
This is just crazy. It makes no
>> Are you saying this? Are you saying this to me because
I said I'm a Leafs fan? you sense.
>> Oh, this is great editing here, by the way. Right. So,
Willie plays a bunch of clips of me saying that I'm so confused
as I'm responding to his arguments. Like, I'm watching what Willie
Mo was saying, and I'm being like, "This is confusing. This is
blah blah blah blah blah." So, Willie splices together every
single time that I said that I was confused to try to paint out
that I just went live like a [__] and had no idea
what I was talking about. Willie deceptively edits that to make
it look like I just went live and I'm like, "What's going on,
guys? I I don't know what's happening."
He had a whole bunch of stuff prepared for his first stream back.
I still haven't gone over that Flamco [__] I should
just ask him, "Hey, can I like can I just yonked your whole Flamco
segment where you read his insane um his insane like Reddit pickup
DMs? That was funny as I listened to that one morning. Holy [__]
Flamco is >> I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I'm just confused, man. Holy [__] I don't know what's
going on." That's how he edits it. But in reality, when you look
at the context of every time I'm I'm responding to him directly.
So that is like actual malicious editing. He's trying to sit
there and act like I was just some [__] just talking
out of my
but in reality this flamco guy this flamco guy had like 15 Reddit
accounts and on every single one of these Reddit accounts he'd
go to r/christianity and like r/bdsm
connections or something and he would message like for DDLGDMs
with women while also arguing about God with people. Like that
was that was the pattern on every single one of these accounts
which to me just strikes me as hilarious. Okay, I
god we should really go over that >> I'm looking at something
stupid that >> it was uh it was Flamco here. Let me pull
it back here. It was Flamco. Augie went over it on the stream
like this stream that's up here. Auggie went over it on that
stream >> to him directly. So that is like actual malicious
editing. He's trying to sit there and act like I was just some
[__] just talking out of my ass. But in reality,
when you watch the stream, I'm looking at something stupid that
Willy's saying, and I'm being like, I'm so confused how you could
be the stupid and be writing this right now. But, you know, w
deceptive editing right there. And that's why Willie Maxaw doesn't
want to debate people. He doesn't want to debate people or attack
people or anything like that or engage with people in a conversation
because he can do stupid like this where he can deceptively edit
the video to make you look like a idiot when that's not what's
going on at all. >> Is confused. It's because he never
plays the original clip that made me mad in the first place.
He just summarizes as they criticize Destiny and that's why Willy's
mad >> too bothered by this but instead bothered by the
stuff that um and JTO were saying and basically what they were
saying was it's kind of hypocritical for Destiny to get upset
at you know Willie Mack for getting doxed when he has a history
of doxing people and is currently right now calling for their
doxes. Right. >> So he never plays the context and then
acts like the reason I'm mad is because they called Destiny a
hypocrite. Nothing about my wedding or my bride. How is that
possible? Unless you're being bad faith. I'm not even >> nothing
about my wedding or bride. Can somebody dissect that argument
that he just made there? I played the queen and clip. I mean,
I watched it before I did that stream. I didn't play it on that
stream, but I played it now. What am I missing here?
>> But he didn't mention that my wedding was being attacked.
What? And also, is that even true? I feel like I did mention
that. >> Oh, what the I mean, maybe I didn't. What does
that have to do with anything?
>> Hold on. I got to hear that again. What are we talking
about? critical for Destiny to get upset at, you know, Willie
Mack for getting doxed when he has a history of doxing people
and is currently right now calling for their doxes, right? >> So,
he never plays the context and then acts like the reason I'm
mad is because they called Destiny a hypocrite.
>> Nothing about my wedding or my bride. How is that possible
unless you're being bad faith? >> So, he's I can only deduce
that what he's saying here is I didn't talk about his wedding
being attacked and his bride being attacked so therefore I'm
engaging in bad faith. Is that is that what we're doing here?
Am am I just completely moronic? Like what is nothing? He mentions
this, but he doesn't mention first of all, he says that I don't
mention like the real reason that he's mad at this clip, which
is that Queen is like, I guess a dog whistler. Okay, well, I've
addressed that point. But then secondly, I don't mention his
bride
or his wedding getting doxed.
So therefore, you didn't mention my wife argu. Well, hold on.
Was the wedding passed yet? I just want to make it clear. The
reason nobody was going to bring up your bride or your wedding
getting doxed is because I think the date hadn't gone by yet.
When was Auggie's stream? Hold on, let's just actually go see
it because I want to say though, the wedding was 26th, 27th,
28th. When was Auggie stream actually? Is this 10 days ago? Right
here. Flamingco leaks. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This was
uh August 1st. Okay. No, it was gone. It was gone by. It was
gone by.
I would say that that was the reason I didn't bring up like what
really happened there, right? Or I was like trying to be koi
about what really happened until I knew the data had gone by
cuz holy [__] It's like I don't want to put any attention
on this. Who says bride it's so weird. H it's whatever.
>> What? This is his CPS. Yeah. It literally feels like
like you have to mention Ethan the CPS call when you attack Ethan
otherwise you're ignoring important context.
Didn't I literally explain that he got doxed in that last stream?
Was that really something that I ignored? Now I'm curious. Right.
I had to have mentioned that Willie Max show. I mean, I I don't
know if I did. I'm sure that I'd said something.
I mean, that just seems I probably didn't go into detail about
it because again, if one of my friends is getting docked, I'm
not going to go into explicit detail about how hard they got
doxed or what happened because I don't want to tell you guys
information about somebody's docs. That's that's uh irresponsible.
I I feel like I had to have mentioned this. I don't know. Let
me just like run through docs real quick. Time stamp or something.
But I did mention it. Sorry. >> The reason I'm mad is because
they called Destiny a hypocrite. Nothing about my wedding or
my bride. How is that possible? Unless you're being bad faith.
I'm not even sure if Auggie knows what a dog whistle is. He's
like, unless Queenman pulls up Willy's docks and >> So,
we're doing two things here. One, we're saying that I'm bad faith.
Willy's using the bad faith tactic, which is code word for I
don't want to gauge what anything that he's saying. I'm just
going to assume that everything he's saying is bad faith. As
if I had some sort of prerogative. What is that? Think about
that for a second. Right. >> I've seen >> I can only
assume some other streamer said the bride thing is weird. Right.
I don't think it's weird at all when they're when they literally
were like in the context of getting doxed. They were going into
their wedding day. I think some other streamer probably said
this and so a bunch of people are like programmed to say it.
Uh I don't think it's weird at all, but >> that bad faith
is like like I have some sort of prerogative like I have a reason
to him over. >> Why? Why would I have a reason to Willie
Max show over? Prior to this video, we were friends. We were
fine. >> I just saw it. >> Why would I go live and
just Oh, I really want to just stick it in Willie Max's back.
I mean, I guess he's just calling me a backstabber,
>> I don't know. >> A knife. A knife he means. I
think he means a knife. >> Why would I be sitting here
like looking to screw Willie Max over? Can you explain that part
of his >> I think it's weird as Okay, go ahead. Let me
hear the bride, not my bride. No, bride to be my bride. My I
I feel like my bride is not weird. Do you really say fiance in
like the week before your your wedding? I don't know. I I don't
think it's I don't think it's weird at all. >> Thought
process.
So he calls me bad faith, but then he also says that I don't
understand. >> Maybe future wife, my future wife would
be better. Future wife, future husband. I I'm just saying in
the context of his wedding day, I don't think it's strange.
But on on like in regular terms, sure. If he just said that,
right, I'd say fiance in the I don't know. It's okay. >> What
a dog was Liz. He's basically just calling me stupid. He's basically
just saying like he doesn't get it. He doesn't understand it,
man. A lot of people don't understand your argument, bro. It's
not because it's some sort of high IQ level argumentation here.
It's actually just because it's stupid. It makes no sense. >> Then
says, "I love doxing Willie. It's all fine." >> Really
a point against Willy Mack. It was mainly a point against Destiny.
I don't think at any point Queen was like, "Yeah, and he got
doxed. I love that." You know, I don't think he ever said that.
So Willie is saying that I, you know, oh well, what do you need
me to have a clip of Queen celebrating me getting docked or whatever?
And it's like kind of I kind of actually do need a clip of Queen
explicitly endorsing or engaging in behavior. Actually controversial
take that's exactly what I >> So I I wouldn't say this.
I maybe Auggie will go like let's say we started building a pattern
of Queen accidentally doxing people and then going ah my bad
guys. Oh no doxing is really bad actually. Right. If we built
a pattern of evidence showing that he was really careless with
people's information and then he played it off with humor and
then it was like do you know what I'm saying? If if this was
a thing that happened a lot, then sure, if we had a pattern of
behavior showing Queen like in other ways was really careless
with people's personal information, right? But I don't think
he has that reputation. I think there's a bunch of streamers
who have way worse reputations than he does.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know, man. >> Yes, I do need
you to >> I would just need a P if you if you want to do
the constructed thing, you need a pattern of behavior. Otherwise,
it's just like, dude, it's it's unironically like what Destiny
tried to criticize me for, right? It's like he has a pattern
of taking advantage of people. He has a pattern of having sex
with people with certain things going on, right? And then he
goes, "Oh, this guy said having pattern having sex with anybody
who has mental illness is no,
no, no, not one time. Go doggies kickst
otherwise go off of speculation that is likely fueled by your
anger, >> which I'm not willing to do. I'm not willing
to throw all my
go along with whatever you're thinking just because ah [__]
it. I trust Willie. >> Okay, hold on. We got to finish
this and then we'll maybe give a comment. >> No, he's he's
not like Kiwi farmer. He's not like on Reddit. >> Give
me a second go on these places sometimes. Maybe on Twitter mainly
Twitter. I think really only use Twitter maybe. He doesn't go
on Reddit, doesn't go Discord, anything. Just Twitter. So if
you don't type that on Twitter, if you don't make announcement,
how will he find out? Huh? You're right. Willie wouldn't have
known. And then Queman, like for all he knows, Queman's still
maliciously doxing him. >> Right. Exactly. So why do you
will he say, "Oh, will he why why would he say that about Queen?"
>> Yeah. No, you're right, dude. I'm uh I'm
>> It's live right now.
>> Exactly. He needs to come in here and and respond right
now. Yeah, join right
>> Okay, that's funny. Let's uh let's finish off so we
can talk for myself and just go along with your version of events.
No, actually I like thinking for
>> and actually I like looking at situations objectively
for what's going
>> I'm not trying to sit here and just go along with your
story. Why? What do I owe that to you? Why? Why do I owe that
to you? Actually, I'm going to think for myself. I'm going to
form my own conclusions. I'm going to I'm going to analyze the
arguments you're making. I'll think about them. I'll hear you
out. But I'm not just going to go along with what your version
of events are just for the [__] of it. Especially
when I think your version of the story is likely tainted.
Well, also Auggie's opinion can now be informed by the fact that
Willie lies about him blatantly. The fact that Willie clearly
lies about Quimman. There's probably some argument like like
Augie had said earlier. If Willie just showed up and went, "Hey,
Quinnman, why are you uh why are you like watching my docs on
your stream?"
He would have just had a massive W, right? would have totally
dunked on Queen still would have had to take everything down.
He would have had to like post something like, right, all he
had to do is go, "Hey, Queen, why'd you watch my docs on your
stream?"
But instead, he just had to hold the L. I don't know why Willie
Mac somehow
in the wake of overwhelming
victory just snatched defeat from the jaws. Okay. Snatch defeat
from the jaws of victory. >> He's almost there, >> which
it clearly is here. He's like, "What? Do you need a clip of Queen
just outright saying it?" Kind of. Or at least something a little
bit more compelling than the evidence you provided. I kind of
do actually.
Anything? Cuz what you're showing me right now ain't it, Docs?
I'd love that. Yo, Emro, thank you for the raid. And Dickers
raided earlier, too. I've got all the See, here's the thing.
The optics, you know, I've got all the spicy chatters raiding
into my stream. So, therefore, it adds credence to the fact that
this is all collusion to [__] over Willy Mack and
make him crazy. The Neo Cabal is supporting me immediately and
stuff like that. Listen, I'm my own man. And I'm just I just
tell it how it is. >> No, Augie's compromised.
>> Augie's compromised. >> Kathy Doyle, Augarc, you're
clearly being dishonest here. Why? Because you can't genuinely
say you can analyze this without your hate of Destiny playing
a significant part. >> Honestly, if Queen censored that
doc, he'd never have been included. Yeah, but who? Wait, who
would have been included? The video wouldn't have existed if
Queen had just censored it. >> Here, I'm willing to call
in right now if you want.
Maybe I want to talk to Willie, but uh if your argument is like
you just hate Destiny, bro, we got to do a little bit better
than that. You're not impressing me. You know >> who was
that? I don't think he ever said that, right? >> Bro, if
you're this stupid, make life better for everybody. >> Oh,
that was Cathy. I see. >> Oh, no.
Dude, quit.
>> Sorry. I'll back it up. >> Bro, if you're this
stupid, make life better for everybody and just quit. Dusty has
recently died. >> Blown the [__] owned. Augie
totally
>> It's over.
>> It's over. >> Oh, no.
Dude, make life better for the rest of us. Ah, got Doc. I love
that. You know, I don't think he ever said that, right? >> Bro,
if you're this stupid, make life better for everybody and just
quit. >> Make life better for everybody and just quit.
Is he telling me to myself? >> Wow. Wow. >> What?
Why are we so mad? What is this?
>> Destiny has recently doxed Jaystalk and Queen. His motivation
behind this is that everyone they associate with him ends up
getting doxed and harassed. >> Okay, hold on. >> You're
this stupid. Make life better for everybody in just >> Okay.
Okay, hold on. I got to just micro analyze this real quick. Let
me hear the clip again. a point against Willy Mack. It was mainly
a point against Destiny. I don't think at any point was like,
"Yeah, and he got docked. I love that." You know, I don't think
he ever said that, right, >> bro? If you're this stupid,
make life better for everybody and just quit. >> So, he
plays the clip of me saying, "I don't think Quan has, you know,
engaged in this sort of behavior. I don't think Queman has celebrated
your docs. I don't think he's made arguments supporting you getting
docks. I don't think he's done anything weird with the docs material."
Blah, blah, blah. And Willie plays that clip and he's like, "Well,
if you're just so [__] stupid, just [__]
quit. Kill yourself." And that's supposed to be like the mic
drop in the video, but he forgets to actually respond to what
I'm saying. Why is what I'm saying stupid? It'd be one thing
if he had like the clip of Quimman being weird or doing something
bad and then he plays that and then he says something like, "Well,
obviously Auggie is a doing his job, so quit." Then you can do
the mic drop moment. But you can't just mic drop immediately
as if that's supposed to be like, "Damn, I I I've been blown
the out here." You have to actually like explain yourself a little
bit. You have to like drop a bomb on me first before you walk
away with the mic drop and go quit, loser. You can't like what?
Okay.
Don't think he ever said that, right? >> Destiny's girlfriend
Dan Saltman and his family, me and my wife. Destiny has recently
doxed JT stalking. His motivation behind this is that everyone
they associate with him ends up getting doxed and harassed. So
he's doing it back to them. The victims I know are Destiny's
girlfriend, Dan. >> So So the funny thing is is Destiny
knows for a fact that a bunch of these docses happened way before
Queen and I were ever like uh openly like against him or covering
him with any regularity, right? Queen had the the Lauren Southern
video, but it's not like he was streaming a ton before or sorry,
it's not like he was streaming about Destiny a ton before this,
right? So he knows I I Man, I'll go through and get it, but he
knows that a whole bunch of people were docked before this and
he is just lying trying to blame this on us, right? He's just
openly lying. I'll go through I'll like actually go through and
collect all the dates or something cuz at this point it's just
crazy that we get blamed for this when all of these people were
doxed way before we had anything to do with with arguing against
with criticizing over his uh his weird predations, right? insultment
in his family, me and my wife in his family. Augie pulls up Destiny's
employees saying she was swatted. >> Okay, so Willie acknowledges
that Destiny has doxed Jtock and Queen >> and he says that's
okay because everyone that hangs out with Destiny gets swatted
and doxed by their communities.
Again, any evidence?
>> Me and my wife touching his family pulls >> He's
going to name people that I'm sure have actually been doxed or
swatted, but again, are we just blaming people? Is are we just
tefl now? Are we just going to just blame people? He doesn't
even have like his argument prepared. He doesn't even have something
ready to make you think that it might be them. He just says it
and you're just supposed to go along with it because you you're
supposed to trust Willie. Just trust him, guys. Why? Show me
something. >> Destiny's employee saying she was >> I
was also swatted.
Now, why would she be saying that she was also swatted
in a reply to this clip? Is she saying that Jaw and Queen had
some part in her getting swatted or that their communities had
some part in this? >> Yes, obviously. But it's all just
a coincidence to Auggie. Augie pulls up another example. >> What?
Again, these No, there's way more entertaining going on. Okay,
get the [__] out of here. >> Responses are
too short. >> Don't come in and ask if I'm covering other
[__] I'm covering this [__] Off. You're
not saying anything. You're just playing clips of me talking
and being like, "Duh." Okay, these are not arguments, Willie.
You're just playing my best moments and pretending like you're
owning me by saying nothing.
I'm sorry, dude. I'm not convinced. You're not showing me anything.
Saying that Jay-Z and Queen had some part in her getting swatted
or that their communities had some part in this. >> Yes,
obviously. But >> obviously, dude, duh. Okay. Well, if
it's so obvious, you should be able to demonstrate that and show
it. >> It's all just a coincidence. >> Do people
just watch this video and just assume that it's based because
it's
>> Is that why is that what we're doing here? to pulls
up another example of a Destiny viewer saying they're getting
threatening letters sent to their house and Destiny's like I
don't believe them but even if that happened it's still not that
community
>> yes what a couple months ago cuz I'm a >> no matter
how many people come out and go this guy rap me and they have
no evidence they've even talked to that person right no matter
how many times there are totally baseless accusations that get
made zero basis at all
they we'll still laugh at them they're still going to be stupid
you have no evidence
fan of Destiny in the JSON server. Someone in his community sent
a letter to my home. I've moved since. This is a ridiculous story,
by the way. This is moronic. This guy's sitting here saying someone
found my address and sent me a letter. They sent me a letter
that said, "You defend Dessi because you want to rap kids and
your wife." >> Hold on. Let me pull this up again. I believe
Hold on.
Let me find I'll find those DMs. I believe he said 98% sure
that it wasn't this community. Let me just pull this up. Let
me pull this up. Let me pull this up. Imager. Imager Odor. Yeah,
this guy is a You just get like high and sitting VCs in the Discord
all day. So, this is his final message to me. What did I say?
I just said like, "Okay, what what did I say before that?"
Oh, I said, "Why didn't you keep this evidence, right? Like,
this would be from a totally unhinged skitso who's like clearly
stalking you in real life." And he was like, this is his response.
As much as you hopefully were joking about our healthcare being
in danger because I'm a nurse. Oh, I wasn't joking. I was saying
if somebody went to your house and dropped off a letter that
was from a Discord about your arguments in a Discord, yeah, you
should create a record of that for the police. And he was like,
I hope you're joking about me being in danger.
No, I'm not. I'm telling you that like literally you should um
you should like keep evidence of this if it really happened.
And then he said, "I'm at a much higher risk of being of a patient
tracking me down, especially the actual psych patients, an unhinged
family I deal with, threat me to my face. They know where I work,
what I look like, and the fir my first and last name, which is
incredibly unique." But to reiterate, I'm like 98% positive that
this wasn't someone from your community. Just wanted to bring
it to your attention. This is him, by the way, saying like, "I
realize you're calling me out for like totally faking this right
now. And so I'm going to make it so you don't feel like you have
to actually prove that I'm lying or or call me out on this."
Right? when he says, "I'm 98% positive it wasn't somebody from
your community."
Yeah, it's pretty obvious where he's going. Like, oh, you you
just called out my obvious, but you know, I don't think it was
anybody from your community. I don't think it was anyone at all.
Some people have awareness and survival skill of a goldfish.
Okay, but you want to go make this claim on the internet. This
isn't even just the survival instinct, right? It's not. It's
it's you also want to make this claim on the internet, so save
the evidence. He's like, "Well, I think everybody would have
just called me a liar anyway." Like, okay. As opposed to now
where we call you a liar and Okay,
>> This anakusparian tweet is is [__] up. >> I
don't believe that. I don't believe that. Show the letter. Show
it. Am I just supposed to believe people's words? Why am I supposed
to just believe everything I see on the internet? I don't. And
even and again, if this happened,
demonstrate to me why Quean and Jtock are responsible
for this behavior. Because all you've done to demonstrate that
is a clip where you think Queman's dog whistling supporting your
docs. We already went through that and we showed why that was
bull. What else do you have? Anything? Anything else?
Then thanks for telling us by the way to my house saying I defend
Destiny because I want to my This is just a skitso post. My wife
and my patience. I'm going to put an X to Dallas on that one.
And even if it did happen, right, who's responsible for that?
Who's responsible? Willie Max show is genuinely, and anyone who
watched this video and liked this video, by the way, what you
are now doing, by the way, is you have now set the narrative
that actually Hassan and Xanderhal were right. When Hassan and
Xanderhal said that you have to police your chat and you have
to be super cautious about what's going on in your own community,
in your own chat, and that you're responsible for your own chat,
what you're saying is they were right all along. If your chat's
racist or whatever, you're racist. If there's people doing bad
things in your chat, you're doing those things or you're responsible
for those things. I'm sorry. I was against that standard in 2020
and I'm against it now. I'm the only single person in this whole
entire story that's being consistent here. That's not letting
myself go crazy
because the people in the story
that are getting accused of all the crimes happen to also be
people that I don't like. Willie,
>> what about the guy dog whistling that I'm a valid target
and getting a dono saying they understand his orders? >> Anything
is justifiable against Destiny and the people who support him.
I don't think creators are responsible for every one of their
unhinged viewers, but it is not normal for a community this small
to have so much doxing coming out of it. >> Oh, so Willie
says, "Well, I don't think you're responsible for your own community."
Then what are we saying? >> I don't think you're responsible
for your community, but also like um also it's not normal for
this many doctors to come out of What doers? You still haven't
shown any docing coming out of these communities? You on that
one. And even if it did happen, right? Who's responsible for
that? >> What about the guy dog whistling that I'm a valid
target and getting a dono saying they understand his order? >> So,
he got a crazy dono.
Somebody could donate right now and say some crazy [__]
Somebody could donate right now and say I'm gonna someone or
whatever. Am I responsible? >> Anything is justifiable
against Destiny and the people who support him. >> I don't
think Nice clip by the way. Nice clip [__] where
Queenman is clearly saying that that's what Destiny's position
is. Not that he supports that standard of mor of morality. But
again, this is Willy's dishonest editing right
>> Creators are responsible for every one of their unhinged
viewers. But it is >> I don't think creators are responsible
for every one of their unhinged viewers. Then what are we arguing
about? >> Normal for a community this small to have so
much doxing coming out of it. >> Where's the doxing? It's
not normal for a community this small to have so much doxing
coming out of it. Where?
You just said that uh Dan Dan Sman's been docked. My me and my
wife have been doxed.
Dan Solman's been docked. You know who else has been? >> Wait,
what?
Doxing coming out of it.
You just said that uh Dan Dan Sman's been doxed. Me and my wife
have been docks.
Dan Solman's been docks. >> Sorry, that's I just thought
that was funny that he said Dan twice. Uh Dan and his family
apparently um
>> what Hutch he he like everybody recently J and Queen.
>> Not true. >> Is only one side of the equation
here getting doxed or is everybody getting doxed? Everyone in
this story is aiac. There's certain parties that are responsible
for the escalation
in this Ethan Klein Destiny Hassan drama. Bad empanada certainly
is respons Badanata and his community are responsible for escalating
things. Destiny and his community are responsible for escalating
things. And maybe you could make the argument Ethan Klein is
as well cuz he's been going after random Redditors and stuff
like that. But the very least definitely Destiny in Bad Empanada.
And I guess also just random people on Kiwi Farms. I mean, Kiwi
Farms is known for being a platform that hosts doces, but even
Kiwi Farms is not some sort of monolithic guy. Kiwi Farms is
not some sort of uh Kiwi Farms is not just one guy who has like
just it's a bunch of rand it's an open form that anyone can sign
up for. That is a cat >> and you're allowed to post whatever
the [__] want and there's a culture that encourages
you to post people's doxes and [__] like that, right?
>> So, random people in farms are doxing. Badata in his
community and his community are for sure. Dude, there's
>> these are the >> dude there's like so much more
content for tonight, too. Like after this. >> But here
almost five we're almost 5 hours into the stream. We've still
got like so much to go over >> and JT. Well, he provides
no evidence other than one person donated something. And apparently
this guy that donated is like a known like a Willy donated. You
know what I mean?
Willie donated was like I'm going to dox this guy. It's like
you're probably talking [__] Either way, I'm not
responsible for that and I'm going to disavow it. Which is what
[__] women did. I've made videos on communist, Nazis,
misogynist, fedist,
millions of followers, yet this tiny little community is where
all this doxing takes place. >> Willie, you are bro, you
made a video on the politics community. Don't you know how vicious
political communities are on the internet, rightwing or leftwing,
they dox.
Everyone knows that Willy's sitting here saying, "I've gone after
massively subscribed YouTubers and I've never gotten this level
of treatment." Yeah, Willie, you stepped into a giant I don't
even want to say culture war. I don't even know. I don't even
know what to call it. you stepped into the Israel Palestine
political,
>> but also
why do we believe that this wasn't a lefty?
Like literally, you've got bad empanadas community right there
who openly docks people, right? Who dox people who are pro- Israel,
who are unapologetically pro-Israel,
how in the do you think that we're more likely to have done something
here than those people? There's no evidence of us ever going
to do people. There's a ton of evidence of us saying we disavow
it. You have an actual culprit who's there who's spreading the
docs and his community who like do actually do this is a valid
tactic. They think it's a valid tactic. Destiny and Dan are raising
the temperature on all of this. Dan's doxing random Twitter users
for Ethan Klein. Why wouldn't why would you expect that you're
not like included in that discourse cancer? >> By the way,
you don't deserve to be. Nobody deserves to be. I'm just saying.
>> World they dox the right-wing doxes. The leftwing doxes.
You have stepped into one of the most toxic, one of the most
venomous communities and you're sitting here acting like you're
surprised that they're this vicious. Did you not know that before
you even got involved? What? Yeah, obviously if you make a video
about Jake Paul, you're probably not going to get doxed. But
if you make a video about bad impanata or you're involved in
this Palestine Israel war, a conflict, not just in real life,
but on the internet that is so vicious, you understand everyone
on both sides is perfectly willing to both sides want to literally
each other. If you're super pro Palestine and you see somebody
that's like pro Israel, you want to kill that person. That is
the standard that has been set long ago. You are in one of the
most toxic conversations that has ever taken place online and
you're acting surprised that, oh, when I make a video about Logan
Paul, I don't get docks, but when I make a video about these
guys, damn, a bunch of [__] happens. It must be Queen
and Jox's fault. No, you [__] Analyze the community
that you're these people are nuts. Everyone is nuts on both sides.
>> And it's just out of their dude. He's literally sitting
there in the Taliban as they constantly repost doces and going,
"Guys, I don't know if we should be reposting doces
and he gets a he's like, I think it's those guys who who who've
denounced doxing every single time it's come up. I think it's
them." No, it's the enemies of the people you're hanging out
with. Obviously,
use your brain for two seconds. >> Dude, they're obviously
feeding into it. But Augie knows nothing. He can't even recite
me boofing on them accurately. J is criticized. >> Okay.
Okay. They're obviously feeding into it. JT and Queman should
have better when they get involved by being a DGG Orbiter. This
Niba Burrito guy has said that Queen was a huge Destiny sick
event before, by the way. Like I actually think that this account
might be chat GPT. Like maybe they figured out how to do this,
right? Like this is this is like crazy levels of illiteracy mixed
with not understanding history or or anything that's happened.
He was, wasn't he? He was not. It's a funny meme. Okay. It's
a funny meme. when I go Queenman's going to beat me for DG of
the year or something. He was never ever ever No. Oh, sorry.
He was a Destiny fan. He was never a Destiny fan while he's a
streamer. He was a Destiny fan in like 2021. Sorry. He was a
Destiny fan in 2021, but he was not an orbiter. He never went
on stream or anything, as far as I know. >> Sure, dude.
I'll just take your word for it. Okay. >> But Auggie knows
nothing. He can't even recite me goofing on them accurately.
J has criticized Destiny for creating a metaphorical rift machine
partially because he had with BPD girl. Then when these girls
call him out for being abusive, everyone thinks they're just
crazy. J stock nut had sex with the same BPD girl. >> Everything
Destiny's saying here is true. Actually, it's not true. Actually,
everything Destiny's saying here is complete. Destiny says, "And
to think that this was the same guy." >> Wait, he actually
said it. Destiny tries to invalidate those people by using by
weaponizing their mental illness against them, right? Despite
entering the relationship knowing that they have this mental
illness. That's like that's just obviously true,
right? That's just obviously true. But that's he literally lays
it out and so he's going to show evidence of me doing that, right?
Jason juice who spent the last year saying having mentally ill
people equals crazy huh no you that was never the argument that
you have >> using your public platform to try to invalidate
these people >> ill people that means you're rap them by
default the argument is that you don't give a about their consent
because you'll share their images videos of them doing all kinds
of stuff you'll share that with anyone >> no Auggie J actually
specifically said it's not about sharing images >> I think
that the main talking point is a Destiny district >> no
Spectre thank you for the 14 months I'm not going to spend a
lot of time explaining this >> and like it's like a weird
se >> I think that's not the same the main talking point
I One of the big I mean a massive talking point here is the infinite
ring machine. Okay. How does the infinite ring machine work?
It's a massive talking point which you know if you're a part
of if you watch the Sunday video it's not just about nudes bro.
It's about a system that let this happen for so long. >> Hey
what the wait is that a clip I'm I'm so confused. Is that a clip
of Jay talk saying that Destiny's people only because he has
people that are mentally
>> What was that clip supposed to blow me out of the water?
Uh your clip doesn't justify your argument, bro. >> It
doesn't even make sense. And he puts it together with the Sunday
clip. Sunday is describing the same system and all the pieces
that go into it. Right? We're both we're both describing the
same system and he like actually just goes and he's like Sunday
as a part of a list of conditions for this thing to perpetuate
for this long. Right? One of them is that Destiny targets mentally
ill people. >> The machine is Destiny targeting mentally
ill women and the victims are also selected. >> Yes, but
it's a machine. It doesn't mean it's it doesn't mean it's just
because they're mentally ill. It's not. Nobody's saying that.
Nobody's saying that. It's when you're going to use that mental
illness to discredit them when they get mad at you. Right. That
Sunday makes that point by the way that you publicly use your
platform to discredit these people because of the mental illness
that you knew about before you engage in the relationship >> either
for mental illness. >> Sorry, just and as soon as they
do complain, yeah, you weaponize that mental illness against
them. >> So they say part of the machine is destiny targeting
mentally ill women >> and the victims are also selected
either for mental illness allowing them to be easily construed
as hysterical or deceptive when they complain about their treatment.
So, when it leaks that JTO is having a secret relationship with
the same BPD girl and she crashes out on him multiple times.
It's funny. I'm giving him I'm allowed to talk back to these
people. I talked to Auggie about the same exact thing a month
ago and told him if he wanted to fight. >> Okay, hold on
now. Obviously, you're allowed to goof on Jtock when Cherry's
exploding on him and there's all this drama going on there, right?
That's >> Nobody gets mad at that, man. >> Fine.
Does he think Does he think that I have an issue with him making
fun of Jtock or Keenan or fighting back in any sort of way?
What? Of course not. No. The thing that I had an issue with specifically
was you saying what Desi was saying was correct. And what Desi
is saying wasn't correct because Desty's acting like, "Wow, Jtock
said I girls because I have people that are mentally ill." Again,
you haven't a clip saying that that's what JTO said. I mean,
they certainly criticize Destiny for constantly going after these
women, mentally ill women. It's the It's the It's how you get
away with mistreating people, right? Is not literal in this sense.
I don't think even Sunday is arguing that Destiny is literally
people. He's not holding people down and penetrating them against
their will, right? There's just a lot of regret for them after.
But I'm saying that the the the is colloquial here. It's like
the infinite the infinite r of people's brains. Okay. The infinite
like destroying of people.
And and then when they do blow up on you for being mistreated
badly, you go, "Oh, that person's just crazy. Well, that's just
a crazy mentally ill." Well, that's just another crazy mentally
ill. It's like the same argument I've been making and everyone's
been making since this [__] first blew up is, "Hey,
it's it's literally the reason I told Willie that the cherry
stuff was important because Destiny's going to try to slander
all these people as mentally ill horses. He's going to try to
slander Pixie as a mentally ill, right? That's what he's going
to try to do. He's going to do it repeatedly. What has he done
since then? Constantly focusing on Pixie.
Constantly trying to paint Pixie as somebody who's like a total
constant constant constant
leaks DMs with Cherry leaks leaks all kinds of [__]
with Cherry, right? Trying to paint them as as just mentally
ill. We we don't have to listen to them, guys. They're just like
the rest. They're just like the rest. They're just like That's
the machine. That's the machine. That's the system. That's the
pattern. That's why you need to call that out. And if you don't
call that out, like Willy over here, you let more people get
hurt.
That's how it is, man. >> But they weren't saying that
he's
>> Um it's because they're invested in
making Destiny look better. That's the only reason you would
do this is because you're invested in making Destiny look better.
If you want to say that I look like a piece of [__]
that's fine. You can say I look like a piece of [__]
I don't care. Okay. I don't care about the opinion of Willie.
He is a complete [__] His opinion means nothing to
anybody who has any level of intelligence. Okay. What I care
about is like the total misconring and the equating of like my
criticisms for Destiny and like what I've things that I've done.
I'm not a hypocrite on this thing other than the e- dating thing.
The e- dating thing which is also not like a moral position.
It's just me making fun of people. That's the only hypocrisy
here. It's the e- dating thing. And that's just funny.
You find it anything more than funny? >> How are we this
stupid here? What the are we saying? >> And you can just
watch the ending to my second Destiny video. But he didn't watch
it. He'd rather make stuff up. Bro, you're sitting at a computer
right now. Feel free to use it. Audience ends this hourong segment
on me summarizing that the only reason I'd be mad is because
I'm stupid or because Destiny controls me. >> I still stand
by this. By the way, >> feeding into the narrative that
got me doxed in the first place. >> It's hard to like
feeding into the narrative that got me doxed in the first place.
Whoa. So now Willy's criticizing me for feeding into the narrative
that got him doxed. What?
Dude, this is So, this is this is the real thing they're doing
here, right? They're going, "Hey, when you talk this way, that
gets me doxed. When you talk about how Destiny has habitually
violated consent, that gets people around him doxed, so you can't
do that. Oh, can you show me evidence of like me talking like
that, getting people doxed? Wait, people weren't getting doxed
before that and now they're getting doxed? No, I didn't say that.
And no, I don't have any evidence. Just stop saying bad things
about me." No.
No. You stop trying to hold a gun to my head and saying I and
say tell me actually for everybody's for everybody's safety you
really need to stop talking about how Desi violates women's consent
for everyone's safety you need to do that no yourself I'm not
doing that you can't threaten me to Willy's doing the same thing
here uh for everyone's safety I think you guys have to stop calling
me a Destiny sweeper cuz uh my wife got doxed actually and and
that's your fault oh can you show me any evidence of that? No,
it's was an anonymous account that posted the docs and yeah I
do constantly post pro Israel content. Uh, and yeah, there's
a bad empanada guy who's aware of me, doxes people all the time
and
amplified this. Yes. Yeah, I'm aware that there are communities
that actually docks that have proof of them doxing that they
happily dox. I understand that I've made enemies of those people,
too. But it's Queman and JC because they say I'm a Destiny sweeper.
Actually, that's what it is. Okay, dude. >> So schizophrenic,
bro. Understand why he's posting this. I mean, the two options
is literally just he's like brain dead right now or he's controlled
opposition. Okay, I would apologize right now to Willie Max show.
I didn't realize that me saying this exact thing in this clip
right here led to him getting doxed. My bad, bro. I didn't know
I was doing that to you. Come on,
>> that's all you could think of. Well, let me give you
a third option. Our wedding is having to prepare for fake bomb
threats and my bride is worried about us and our family getting
shot. >> So, what does that do? What? And
>> what does that prove? Uh, let me give you a third option.
Our wedding is getting attacked and my wife's about to get or
whatever. Okay, so that would tie my first argument in which
that you're emotional. Yes. But still, I said he's either or
controlled opposition. Willie Max show is like his rebuttal to
that is, "Dude, I was getting attacked and I was scared." Okay,
so you were >> And also, if you're going to do that, I
I was getting attacked and I was scared. Then you have to come
and apologize, right? You have to say, "Oh, my bad, guys. I freaked
out. My bad. I'm sorry. I said some things that weren't true."
You don't double down and post a video accusing Queen's community
of doxing you. You don't get to play that card and also double
down on the thing that you're trying to get the out on, right?
You're trying to get an out for saying stupid while doubling
down on it. How? How is that possible? >> Maybe it's justifiable
why you were being because you just weren't thinking clearly.
You weren't thinking straight. But that still doesn't that just
goes into my first option I gave. Okay. And this guy's telling
me to leave the internet. By the way, this guy picks a fight
with the most toxic, the most cancerous corner of the internet.
Loses his but tells me to leave. Okay. >> He never once
brings this up as a possibility for why I'm frustrated. It doesn't
cross his mind. Seriously, if that's the extent of your analysis,
you need to quit. in my last >> second time. But yeah,
there he goes again. You need to quit. You mad, bro. Are you
mad? >> Conversation with Auggie. He told me a >> Oh,
here we go. Get a load of this. Get ready for Will Max's final
punishing
>> Once brings this up as a possibility for why I'm frustrated.
It doesn't cross his mind. Seriously, if that's the extent of
your analysis, you need to quit. In my last conversation with
Augie, he told me a story about how he quit drama for a year
because a guy named Salvo was doxing and harassing him and his
family. So, where is that same sympathy when it's happening to
me and my wife?
>> That's like a crazy thing to leak out of nowhere. So
now Willie Maxo is just leaking conversations that we've had.
Tipster says hot [__]
Let me explain this conversation. Now I'm not the type of guy
that likes discussing private conversations like this. I think
that that's pretty nasty. But Willie Max opened up the uh the
floodgates here. Okay. You want to try to throw me under the
bus? You know, I'll do the same thing to you. Do you know why
this conversation took place? He's referencing a conversation
a month ago that we had. A lot of people in my community were
suggesting that I should host a debate between Quimman and Willie
Mac Show. So I called Willie Mac Show. half just kind of just,
you know, talks with them to see what's going on. I was kind
of bored or whatever. I just wanted to like >> [__]
I'm like half >> I'm like thinking of some other stuff
in the background. I'm getting like super annoyed with this whole
thing.
>> Um,
at what point do I feel compelled when I keep getting blamed
or when Queen keeps getting blamed, at what point is it like
no longer and the people who are the people who got doxed are
going, "Yeah, this Queen and JTO guy seems like they're doxing
people." At what point am I allowed to just go and compile all
of the people who have gotten docks in that thread and say here's
all the people who got docked before this and now here are the
people who are going to get docked or here are the people who
got docked after and like just differentiate and show like here
are the people you could possibly blame me for. If you're not
on this list, shut the [__] up. Wait, what? Do you
guys not hear me? Oh, what are you guys talking about right now?
Who? Hold on. Am I missing something in the chat right now? Jesus.
Sorry. I'm like I'm like getting super annoyed with just like
the idea that I'm going to get blamed for these doces that happened
when I was still a friend with of Destiny's community.
Like it's it's just crazy that like Destiny had an unhinged stalker.
It was why he stopped like letting women walk by his room or
whatever. It's why he put that curtain up and and then I'm going
to get blamed for that. Like you actually >> this debate
to him, right? >> And I don't want to do that. I don't
want have to go through and say, "Hey, I didn't like I didn't
dox these people. These people were doxed before. I don't want
to have to do that. But literally, the people who weren't docked
before are coming out and like blaming me. Coming out leaning
on that.
>> That's insane. >> Hey, Marty Epstein, thanks for
the gifted sub, buddy. We are
actually there. We're We're there for the extra hour on stream,
guys. Let's go. We got that extra hour. Two hours 28 minutes.
Boom. Boom.
Thank you very much, Morty Epstein. Let's go. Let's not forget
Tessi had plans to kill the child. I'm just saying that like
I feel like I'm going to reach out to some of these people privately
and just be like, "Hey, I feel like I'm compelled to go and like
show this evidence now. Um if you're if you guys are going to
lean into this, if you're not going to call Destiny out at all,
I'm going to have to go and say here are the people that were
that this happened to before I was involved because I'm I'm sorry.
You can call this guy out or I can go and like compile this list
and post it." I'm probably not going to do that, but that's how
I that's how I feel. Okay, I'm venting. I'm probably not going
to do that. But it's like unfortunately if you if people just
keep lying, like if you guys if you guys want to lie and blame
me for this, then I might as well might as well absolve myself
by at worst doing the thing you're already accusing me of. >> And
so I proposed this debate idea, not thinking that, you know,
he's going to go on with it, right? I propose this >> What
is the steel man for why people so regularly accuse this and
Queen's community of doxing? Because
oh, it's like not even there's not even really a great steelman.
It's like this community doesn't like Destiny. This community
was probably Destiny's like biggest fan community. Okay.
And then this stuff dropped and this community turned on Destiny.
And for a long time, like anytime Destiny talked about this community
or talked about me, people would just say like somewhat unhing
like talk about how his dick is gross or other [__]
We had memes that were like making fun of his stupid like fimosis
and [__] And yeah, that happened for a little bit
and I can understand why that would be upsetting to him. We talked
a lot of but it wasn't doxing, right?
And so because because there's like overlap and some people because
like my memes that happen on my stream or Queman's stream end
up on Kiwi Farms and they like free say them, right? He feels
like he can say, "Well, you guys say jokes that are on Kiwi Farms
because we made them, right?" And and that's proof that you guys
are like coordinating with these people. I I honestly can't even
do a like a steel man. I It's like actually difficult for me
to do a steel man on why he would say we're doxing people. And
I believe if he had any evidence of it, he would have posted
it. The evidence that he posts is these guys really don't like
me. Yeah. Nobody's denied that we really don't like you. Yeah.
Anyway, >> idea to him. And he starts ringing off at like
a thousand [__] words per minute about how much Jaw
and Queen have just been complete pricks to him. How their communities
have been cancerous. How everything has just been so terrible.
They're dishonest. They're liars. Blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah. And so I'm sitting there saying I'm like, "Okay, you know,
I know what it's like. I've dealt with communities attacking
me before, right?" And I mentioned that. Pretty sure I didn't
tell him that that's why I left YouTube because that doesn't
even make any sense, right? When did Salo when was Sabo going
after me? Like September 2022 and when did I leave? Like a year
later. Didn't I start a whole daily show on Red Fox 6 months
after that? Why would I have wanted to let the internet >> like
Yeah. So Destiny's been using the H3 thing. A lot of the arguments
about the H3 snark people to like go after my community. And
like some of his evidence is like people posted a picture of
him out for a walk with the cat and were like, "Look at this
guy. He's got like no testosterone. He can't even hold on to
that cat." That's like the level of comment that he's like, "This
is totally unhinged and insane." Honestly,
the the person who talked the most, the most the most vile [__]
the worst was Kelly. And she's not around anymore. And Destiny
doesn't even get mad at Kelly. He's not even mad at her. He's
not targeting her in any way, right? But like that's the person
who said the most unhinged about him. That's what's funny to
me is it's so clearly disingenuous just in his criticisms of
my community. They like totally gave Kelly a pass cuz she doesn't
like me now. Wrote it out for a year and also started a brand
new show in that same amount of time. But then a year later when
nothing's going on, nothing's happening. That's when I decided
this. I can't handle what happened a year ago. Really? Obviously
that doesn't make any sense. >> Oh, we're never bringing
back Kelly. We're good. >> Right. The reason why I left
is very simple. I was just bored of this. I was bored of this
and I wanted to work on other things. That's pretty much it,
right? And obviously there's other factors that contributed to
it. One of those being, you know, which was a point that I was
making was that, you know, when you're on the internet, when
you're a commentator, there are cancerous elements to it, like
people attacking you and stuff like that. >> Uh, you didn't
hear that before. I literally never said that before. I literally
never would have said that before. It's like a totally different
personal thing now. >> Attacking your family and things
like that. So, I for sure mentioned that to him, but not in like
this is why I left. And here's the thing, too, right? I didn't
record that call. So, I can't even prove this to you guys, right?
But you know who thought that I was recording that call? Willie.
Because I'm sitting here relating to him. I'm saying like, "Hey,
dude. Like, you know, I get it. I've had communities attack me
before. It sucks." I'm telling him this so that he understands
that I know where he's coming from. But as he's telling me more
and more about what Queen and J have been doing to him, I start
pushing back because I want to hear more about that. As soon
as I start pushing back, he gets nervous all of a sudden. He's
like, "Dude, are you just farming me? Are you just recording
me?" And I'm like, "What the fuck?" I said, "Screen sharing my
uh my desktop window and I flip my camera on and stuff like that."
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Screen sharing. Okay, cuz when
he was on Chud Augie said, oh, well, I turned my camera on and
said I'm not recording it. I'm like, wait, what? How did that
give him like 80 piece? But he recording it, but I'm like, dude,
I'm I'm your [__] I'm not going to record you. The
hell what do you think? I'm like taping you to give it to Queen
tomorrow so that he can go over it on stream.
But that's the level of paranoia that we're dealing with here.
Even when I'm talking in private and Willie is privately expressing
to me how much Queen Miman and Juck have run a train on him mentally
even in that
Oh, that's
Did you hear that?
Apparently apparently me and Quan are brutally double penetrating
this guy's brain. Obviously this is a joke. This is totally fake.
It would be maybe the gayest It would basically just His brain
is so tiny it would basically just be doxing to try to double
penetrate it. Okay. Like it would be it would be the most gay
act you could do. All right. It's so small. It would just be
docking. Okay. I No thank >> He thinks that I'm out to
get him at the same time. >> You know, he thinks that I
might be after him or something like that. And I got to be honest,
too. So Chud Logic had me on a show this morning, right? Chudlogic
had me on a show this morning and Chud mentioned on stream that
he's like, "Hey, I messaged you. I checked my Discord, right?
I didn't see any messages from Chud and then I realized, oh,
he's probably messaging my old Discord account cuz I have two
Discord accounts, right? He's probably messaging my old one,
the Aug RC account." Desi said, "Riyle deleted his YouTube. Is
that true?" I hope not, but you know, people go super unhinged.
I really hope not. No, his YouTube's not deleted. I don't know
why Desi would have said that. I don't know if he's posted in
a little bit, but
anyway, we >> lo into that account. >> Sorry, I got
to get through this cuz Auggie said he'd call in once I'm done.
I'm only going to go to the end of the Willie segment here. I'm
not going to go to all the bad empanada >> so that I can
respond to Chud and I can go on to the show. As I log into that
account, I see a mis red DM for Willie Max show and he had messaged
me a day before I went live. He messaged me a day before I went
live asking if he wanted to play video games with me. And I'm
sitting there going, I'm like, "Oh man, dude, I missed I missed
that DM." What would have happened most likely if if I was like
using that Discord account, I would have seen that DM. We would
have called each other, played some video games, and I might
have mentioned like what was going on with his Twitter account.
I might have disagreed with him, right? and my stream that I
did the next day probably would not have been as just naturally
people are going to say, "Oh, it's a balls rail ball sweeping."
Look, as human beings, of course, if I have like a conversation
with somebody and I talked to them, I'm most likely not going
to be as harsh towards them as I would if I didn't have that
conversation clearly, right? But here's what I'm thinking. This
is what I'm getting down to, right? I think Willie Max show,
this is just me speculating. I think he assumed, he probably
saw I was online on Steam and playing games and I was just blowing
him off, right? Not knowing that I just didn't use ideas going
out. I think that he thinks that I was blowing him off and then
he sees the next day I do a stream >> and in his mind he
probably at that point was like this guy's a piece of he's after
me >> and that's why he's calling me bad faith in this
video. That's what I honestly >> What I really think is
disgusting here on Augie's part is that he pretends he doesn't
have that Discord account at all. He pretends he pretends he's
not on that Discord account. All right. Gaslights Willy Mack
and says, "Oh, I didn't have access to it." While playing Steam
games the whole time to make sure Willie knows that he's on his
computer. He could talk. He could play games with you. Maybe
he was even playing like Battlefield or something, some multiplayer
game, just to let Willie know how up how up the mind of Auggie
is. Okay, Auggie is just like torturing him. And then Auggie
goes live the next day, fires up the stream, and is like, "We're
going to blow Willie Mac the day. [__] this loser."
I honestly believe that because I didn't play video games with
him the day before and then the next day I happened to go live
on him and his takes. He probably thought that I was ignoring
him the previous day because I had already made the decision
in my own mind that Willie Max has cancer and I'm after him.
I actually believe that's what happened. And maybe I'm wrong,
okay? I'm purely speculating here, but that honestly makes the
most amount of sense to me right now. I think that's what happened
because you notice in this video he calls me bad faith. He says
I'm a piece of and stuff like that. He went hard as and it was
personal, right? Even this point he's making right now is a personal
attack that he's making against me. And so I'm sitting here thinking
I'm like damn like Willie Masho really I know I obviously I should
talk to him on my stream but I didn't think that what I did warranted
this right.
I think that he thinks that I like turncoded him or something
and that's why he decided to just let it all out there. I think
that's honestly what happened.
This whole thing was a major misunderstanding that could have
been resolved
but instead now it's escalated to this. But you know what? I
said this >> that not J-ST account is there. Apparently,
they're going to post segments, right? So, we'll see how it goes
with the the notjstock account. Um, not_jtock.
I don't know who this is, by the way. I I literally don't know
who this this person is. It's not undersc_jtock like this. Yeah,
I don't know who this is, but apparently they're posting like
YouTube videos or something. I don't know. Apparently, couple
up there. I I don't know if it's Riy or what. What the [__]
going on? I don't know who it is. You want to try doing it? I
said, "Listen, you want to post you want to post videos and collect
all the revenue, you go ahead." No, Ri's not gone. I don't think
Ri's gone anywhere. I just That account started. I don't know
who that account is. >> Tried Logic Stream and I am going
to say it now. I'm glad it happened this way because I really
got to see Willie Max show's true nature here. >> I mean,
this video was malicious. It was an attack. He does lie in this
video. He maliciously reframes all of my arguments. He's acting
like I have no He outright says, "Dude, you told me Sava went
after your mom and and yeah, you had no sympathy for when I got
doxed." I absolutely had sympathy. The But he assumes that I
didn't. Probably because he thinks that I'm I'm just willing
to buddy up and ally with the the other team, the team that's
going after him, and giving him a hard time. No, I just look
at people fairly injectively with both the I assume his Twitter
was getting like totally brigaded like mine is, like Queensman's
is, like everybody's is. I assume he's just getting like totally
brigaded and it's like demotivating. you don't really want to
be on that Twitter anymore. So >> my own eyes if you have
>> Also Riyle doesn't have to go on streams or anything
like he just clips, right? So like technically he could just
make a new name and come back as somebody else. For all I know,
he's that not Jaw guy. >> Somebody that I'm talking to.
I'll hear you out. I'll listen to you. But I'm not going to just
form my own opinions around somebody based solely off of what
somebody else is telling me. When I see the abhorrent behavior
from Queen and JF's community, I'll talk about it. I'll call
it out. I'll be like, "What the [__] are we doing
here?" I honestly have not seen that. And this video has not
convinced me otherwise. So, I don't know what I'm supposed to
say. >> He shares the same empathy meter with >> You
know, my empathy meter's only maybe. >> Haha. Idubbb's
meme. >> A guy named Salvo was doxing and harassing him
and his family. So, where is that same sympathy when it's happening
to me and my wife? He shares the same empathy meter with Ian.
>> You know, does he really believe that I was cool with
this or that I didn't care? Does he really believe I didn't give
a that he got doxed? I did. Now, I didn't DM him about it, but
it's like the you know, I didn't know I had to express that I'm
anti-doxing again. Should I have sent him a [__]
Are we back with Bolax territory? You didn't DM me enough, dude.
Sorry, bro. I'm not good at DMing people. I'll admit,
but >> my empathy meter's only maybe like a quarter of
the way filled up. >> Most reassuring news I got was when
my wedding planner told me that she talked to the venue and they
told her that the riff wrap doesn't bother them because they've
done celebrity weddings and that they're in a neighborhood so
they're used to getting calls like this and bro >> sense
very reassuring because it means our venue wasn't spooked and
in another sense very depressing because it means people are
just calling and harassing this place because they're in a neighborhood.
I don't know what should happen when it comes to Destiny or Snark
community doxing each other and others. But what I do know is
Batman needs to ban. He nstop slanders people, doxes people and
harasses them. I don't know what's I don't know what should happen
to Destiny or the Star community doxing each other.
>> Why aren't they all bad then? >> Recently swed
crap by falsely reporting them to the Austrian police for hacking
his old Twitter accounts. I don't think they were ever hacked
at all. >> He accuses me of hacking. Bad banana accuses
me of hacking. Specifically, he accuses me of hacking 15 of his
banned Twitter accounts. >> His evidence of crowd hacking
him comes from a tweet where Crouch says he's archiving his accounts.
That's literally >> This here is the central claim. He
claims I got illegal access to 15 of his 22 temporarily. >> All
right, that's the segment he did on me. Now, I mean, I said I'd
watch this whole thing. We can watch if you guys want. Most of
most of the rest of this video, I think I'm just going to agree
with him on. I mean, he's going to on Banana Panata some more.
He's going to on Hassan some more. I agree with that. I mean,
>> okay, I'm going to >> I don't think this part
is super relevant to I agree with it. You know, I'll just flat
out say anything that happens for the rest of this video, why
endorse.
I